Hey everybody, really excited about this episode. So the internet is actually kind of an amazing thing that even I would say Patrick and I largely take for granted. I think at one point there was a networking course. I never took it, actually. But Patrick, you might have taken it. So I know very little. I know that there is all these layers. There's like an IP layer and a TCP layer, but very superficial. It just seems like dark magic and wizardry that I can just reach out and connect to just about any public server on the whole web. It's pretty remarkable. Never actually, to be honest, understood how it works all the way down.
大家好，非常高兴能录制这期节目。说实话，互联网其实是一个相当了不起的东西，甚至连我也不得不承认，帕特里克和我大体上都把它当成理所当然的事。我想当年曾有过一门网络课程，其实我从来没上过。不过帕特里克，你可能上过。所以其实我知之甚少。我只知道里面有很多层，比如有IP层和TCP层，但也仅限于非常肤浅的了解。我只需要伸出触角，就能连接到整个网络上的几乎任何一个公共服务器，这感觉就像是黑魔法和巫术一样。真的很了不起。老实说，我其实从来没有真正彻底搞懂过它底层的运作原理。
And so really, really excited that we have John Day, who's a professor at Boston University, who's going to really dive in and explain to all of us how this actually works and how it came about and what were all the sort of design points made along the way and that whole evolution. So thank you so much for coming on the show, John. Thank you. Cool. So, you know, we always kind of start by talking to people about, you know, the pandemic. I mean, I know we're kind of hitting the tail end as far as, you know, let's say like lifestyle disruptions. I don't know what the data is on the actual pandemic itself, but so how did you kind of weather all of that?
所以，我们非常非常高兴地请到了波士顿大学的教授约翰·戴（John Day），他将深入为我们大家讲解这一切究竟是如何运作的、它是怎么诞生的、在整个发展过程中做出了哪些设计要点，以及它整体的演变过程。非常感谢你能来到节目中，约翰。谢谢。太棒了。那么，你知道的，我们通常会先和大家聊聊关于大流行的话题。我的意思是，我造这可能已经接近尾声了，至少在生活方式受到干扰这方面是这样。关于大流行本身的具体数据我不太清楚，不过你当时是怎么挺过这一切的呢？
What did you do during the lockdown? Did you still teach? How did that all go down for you? Actually, it was pretty normal. We went to teaching online. Actually, I was at a conference in Paris the last week of February. And we got in just as everything was shutting down. I came home.
你在封城期间都做了些什么？你还在上课吗？这一切对你来说是怎么过去的？其实挺正常的。我们转成了线上教学。实际上，二月的最后一周我在巴黎参加一个会议。就在一切都在关停的时候，我们赶了回来。我回到了家。
I taught a week, was going to go to Phoenix to see my grandchildren. And on spring break, and we shut down right then. And I said, I think I'll stay here, which was for sure. Because I probably wouldn't have been able to get back. Yeah, right, right. But we went online. And I worked right out of where I am now. Since I don't have kids I have to muck around with.
我教了一周的课，本来打算去菲尼克斯看望我的孙子孙女。正赶上春假，然后我们就在那时封城了。我说，我想我还是待在这里吧，这绝对是个明智的选择。因为我可能根本回不去了。对，没错，没错。但我们转成了线上。我就在我现在这个地方办公。既然我没有需要操心的小孩，
I didn't really have much reason to go out. That makes sense. What are things like now? Are universities still online? I haven't been really much reason to go out. That makes sense. What are things like now? Are school, are universities still online? I haven't been really coming up with that. No, we went back last fall. Okay. Most everybody did.
我其实也没什么必须出门的理由。这倒说得通。现在情况怎么样？大学还在上网课吗？我其实没怎么关注这个。没有，我们去年秋天就复课了。好的。基本上所有人都是。
The local schools have been meeting since fall. They've gone back as well. There's been a big debate about masks and stuff, of course. Right, right. Things are pretty much back to normal. Very cool. I'm actually going to, there's a bunch of conferences coming up. There's CVPR, ICML, and then there's NeurIPS in December.
当地的学校从秋季开始就一直在面授了。他们也已经复课了。当然，关于口罩之类的事情，自然有过一番激烈的争论。对，对。情况基本上已经完全恢复正常了。太酷了。我实际上打算去，接下来有一堆会议要开。有CVPR、ICML，还有十二月份的NeurIPS。
And I'm going to SciPyCon. And so there's this huge mixture this year. There's some conferences where it's pretty much all virtual. There's some where it's pretty much all virtual. There's some where it's mostly in person. There's some that kind of say you could do either or. And so it seems like no one really knows how many people are actually going to show up. What's the whole conference scene like for you this year? Oh, right now I have nothing scheduled. Yeah. Yeah. That makes sense. Yeah. I have a feeling the conferences are going to be sparse.
我还要去SciPyCon。所以今年情况非常杂。有些会议基本上全是虚拟的。有些会议基本上全是虚拟的。有些则是大部分在线下举行。还有一些可以说是两者皆可。所以看起来没有人真正知道到底会有多少人出席。对你来说，今年的整个会议情况是怎样的？哦，目前我什么都没安排。对。对。这倒合理。对。我有种预感，今年这些会议的人数会非常稀疏。
I'm getting to the point where I, you know, I choose, choose them carefully. Yep. That makes sense. Totally. Awesome. So why don't you kind of, uh, walk us back a bit and kind of talk about your, uh, kind of path, you know, your career path and kind of what got you to, uh, being a professor, what made you choose to go into academia versus industry and path and kind of what got you to being a professor? What made you choose to go into academia versus industry? And kind of what's your whole background? I guess I would have said I'm very fortunate. As I always tell people, I grew up in a town of 900 in Southern Illinois, a very rural farm community. I had the largest high school graduating class they'd ever had, 42. Nice.
我开始觉得，你知道的，我会仔细地进行选择。没错。这说得通。完全同意。太棒了。那么，你为什么不带我们稍微回顾一下，聊聊你的，呃，你的职业心路历程，是什么让你成为了一个教授，是什么促使你选择进入学术界而不是工业界？你的职业心路历程，是什么让你成为了一个教授？是什么促使你选择进入学术界而不是工业界？你的整体背景又是怎样的？我想我会说自己非常幸运。正如我经常对人们说的那样，我在伊利诺伊州南部一个只有900人的小镇长大，那是一个非常偏远的农场社区。我有过他们办学史上人数最多的高中毕业班，一共42人。不错。
And then I got admitted to the University of Illinois, which was a bit of a culture shock. 35,000 students, most of them from Chicago. One of the better engineering schools in the country. So actually, one thing real quick, is University of Illinois the same as UIUC or are those two different universities? Yeah, it's UIUC. Ah, okay. Okay, cool. Yeah. And it was very lucky I fell in with a bad crowd. And there were two parts to the bad crowd. One was we were building the world's first supercomputer called ILLIAC-4, which was a 64 processor machine. And I was part of the operating system group.
然后我被伊利诺伊大学录取了，这算是一种文化冲击。3万5千名学生，其中大多数来自芝加哥。这是全国最好的工程学院之一。所以，说个题外话，伊利诺伊大学和UIUC是同一所大学，还是两所不同的大学？对，就是UIUC。啊，原来如此。好的，酷。对。我很幸运地混进了一帮损友当中。这帮损友分为两个部分。一部分是我们在建造世界上第一台超级计算机，名叫ILLIAC-4，这是一台拥有64个处理器的机器。而我是操作系统小组的一员。
And a part of that group were collaborating a lot with a very charismatic, very smart professor by the name of Heinz von Forrester, one of the four founders of cybernetics, who really put us through the wringer. He didn't tolerate sloppy thinking, and neither did we. And so it was a good match. It had a great effect on how I think. Building ILLIAC 4 had a lot of technical and political problems along the way so since we were the largest military contract on campus we were being uh demonstrated against
该小组的一部分成员与一位极具个人魅力、非常聪明的教授进行了大量合作，他叫海因茨·冯·福斯特（Heinz von Forrester），是控制论的四位创始人之一，他真的是把我们好好操练了一番。他对草率的思考零容忍，我们也是。所以这真是不谋而合。它对我的思维方式产生了巨大的影响。在建造ILLIAC 4的过程中，一路上遇到了很多技术和政治问题，因为我们是校园里最大的军事合同项目，所以有人针对我们进行示威抗议，
for trumped up reasons it was really hilarious it appears that that, okay, the Daily Illini, the student newspaper, wanted to be a leader of the radical movement. And a Vietnamese study program had been sort of snuck onto the Southern Illinois University campus. And they wanted to make the case that the same thing had happened with iliac 4 and this was terrible and it was going to be doing research you know classified research and all this bad stuff and they their proof was it was never anything about the board of trustees was never reported in the student newspaper well two of our guys one guys i work with closely went down to the local newspaper and dug through the archives and found that, well, every time there was a decision to be made, it was covered by the local papers. So in a debate on campus between the two of them and the radicals, this came up and we said, well, see, it wasn't secret at all.
理由可以说是匪夷所思，真的太荒谬了。看起来，呃，《伊利诺伊日报》（Daily Illini），也就是学生报纸，想要当激进运动的领袖。当时有一个越南研究项目被偷偷塞进了伊利诺伊大学南部的校园。他们想要证明的是，ILLIAC 4也发生了同样的事情，这太可怕了，它将从事研究，你知道的，机密研究以及所有这些坏事，而他们的证据就是，董事会的任何相关事情都从未在学生报纸上报道过。好吧，我们的两个伙伴，其中一个与我密切合作的伙伴，去了当地的报纸，翻阅了档案，发现其实每次有需要做出的决定时，当地报纸都有报道。因此，在校园里他们与激进分子的一场辩论中，这件事被提了出来，我们说，看吧，这根本不是什么秘密。
It was out there in the public. The student newspaper just preferred to cover the fraternity and sorority news and not the actions of the board of trustees on LA Act 4. So did you feel like when you were having these debates and being challenged in this way, you're looking back on it. So you kind of say you're really, you know, super focused. You had this advisor who, you know, didn't tolerate fools, right? And so you were really focused on that. But then you have this huge distraction, right? So you do have to kind of tolerate the fools, right?
它早就公开了。只不过学生报纸更喜欢报道兄弟会和姐妹会的新闻，而不是伊利诺伊大学董事会对ILLIAC 4的行动。那么，当你进行这些辩论并受到这种挑战时，你现在回过头来看，你觉得自己当时非常专注？你有一位“对傻子零容忍”的导师，对吧？所以你真的很专注。但与此同时，你遇到了这个巨大的干扰，对吧？所以你还是不得不去应付那些傻子，对吧？
So how do you handle that? Well, you know, we actually used to go out and demonstrate and then come to work. I mean, come on. No, but, you know, after that, then they said, well, we don't think classified research should be done on campus. And we said, neither do we. That's why nothing in this project is classified. Ah, right. And in fact, the building it's supposed to go into is not a secure building.
那你当时是怎么处理的呢？嗯，你知道的，我们其实以前经常出去游行示威，然后回来上班。我的意思是，拜托。不，但是，你知道的，在那之后，他们说，嗯，我们认为机密军工研究不应该在校园里进行。我们说，我们也是这么想的。这就是为什么这个项目里没有任何东西是机密的。啊，对。事实上，它打算搬进去的那栋大楼甚至都不是一个安全保密建筑。
So they didn't want to believe that. However, what was really interesting is one of the reasons for building this machine was to push LSI technology. This is 1970. Now, what's LSI? You have to tell me. Large-scale integrated circuits. Ah, okay. Got it.
所以他们不愿意相信这一点。然而，非常有趣的是，建造这台机器的原因之一是为了推动大规模集成电路（LSI）技术的发展。当时是1970年。那么，什么是LSI？你得告诉我。大规模集成电路。啊，好吧。明白了。
Okay. to tell me large scale integrated circuits ah okay got it okay before we put processors on chips i mean the first chips i saw had a few gates on them wow right this was lots of gates you know doing you know functions on chips and so texas instruments had the contract to do it, but they couldn't do it for the price that they negotiated. So they put their legal legals to work and got out of the contract. So instead of having chips that were about the size of a quarter, they became circuit cards that were probably eight inches high and 18 inches long. Wow. Like a graphics card, almost like a modern day, you know, GPU or something. Instead of the machine being the size of a mainframe at that time, you know, a few cabins, the machine was 10 feet high,
好吧。你得告诉我。大规模集成电路。啊，好吧。明白了。好吧。在我们把处理器做成芯片之前，我的意思是，我见过的第一批芯片上面只有几个门电路。哇，真的。这是大量的门电路，你知道的，在芯片上执行各种功能。所以德州仪器（Texas Instruments）接下了这个合同来制造它，但他们无法以协商好的价格完成。于是他们的法务部门开始运作，并设法解除了合同。所以，芯片本该只有25美分硬币那么大，结果却变成了大概8英寸高、18英寸长的电路板。哇。就像显卡一样，几乎就像现代的GPU什么的。这台机器本该只有当时的大型机那么大，也就是几个机柜，结果它却有10英尺高，
eight feet deep and 50 feet long. Okay? The building it was to go into had no heat, just more air conditioning in the summer. Okay. You know, and the whole, but the whole other aspect of this, now, actually, this was a vector machine. So it was a, you know, know single instruction multiple data stream machine
8英尺深，50英尺长。好吧？它要搬进去的那栋大楼甚至没有暖气，夏天只有更多空调。好吧。你知道的，而且整个，但这一切的另一个方面，实际上，这是一台向量机。所以它是一台，你知道的，单指令多数据流机器，
you know parallel processing in that sort of brute force way not terribly interesting however we were given the job of putting ourselves on something called the arpanet now that was a heck of a lot more interesting. And so we were the sixth system to go live on the net. As I always tell people my original network address is 12. Not 12 dot 12. There's only one octet? Oh, the maximum number of addresses was 64. Nice. Nice. Okay.
以那种蛮力方式进行并行处理，其实并不是特别有趣。然而，我们被派了一个任务，把我们自己连上一个叫做ARPANET的东西。那可就有趣多了。于是我们成为了全网第六个上线的系统。正如我常对人说的那样，我最初的网络地址是12。不是12点12。只有一个字节吗？哦，地址的最大数量是64个。不错。不错。好吧。
I mean, come on, guys. So actually, so physically, how did the machines back then, you know, I mean, was it phone lines or something? Well, okay. As you probably knew, the ARPANET consisted of switches, which were Honeywell 516 minicomputers, which were about the size of a rack. Actually, they came in a militarized container that was a little over six feet high and probably about three feet by three feet. Wow. You've seen the pictures of Kleinrock's first installation on the web. And we all had one of those.
我的意思是，拜托，伙计们。所以实际上，在物理上，当年的机器是如何连接的，你知道的，是通过电话线之类的吗？嗯，好的。正如你可能知道的那样，ARPANET由交换机组成，这些交换机是霍尼韦尔516小型计算机，大约有一个机架那么大。实际上，它们装在一个军事化的容器里，高略超六英尺，大概三英尺乘三英尺。哇。你见过克莱因罗克（Kleinrock）在网上发布的第一个安装实例的照片吧。我们每个人都有一台那样的机器。
There were incredibly fast lines connecting them. 50 KB. Well, I mean, computers in those days had a hard time, you know, keeping that pipe full. Yeah. I mean, this was lightning speed. Okay. I mean, remember was lightning speed. Okay. I mean, remember, in 1971, I had a terminal at home that was 300 bits per second. Wow, 300 baud modem?
连接它们的线路快得惊人。50KB。我的意思是，那时的计算机很难让那个管道保持饱和。是的。我的意思是，这简直是闪电般的速度。好吧。我的意思是，请记住，这简直是闪电般的速度。好吧。我的意思是，请记住，在1971年，我在家里有一个终端，速度是每秒300比特。哇，300波特的调制解调器？
Yeah. So, Patrick, what was your... I remember I had, I think, a 2400 baud modem when I was like nine years old. Patrick, what was your first internet experience? I was high speed. I was like 28k, man. Oh, you started with 28k. Then they had the 56 and there was something about the 56 that was special. Like it had switches or something. They went to 56k dial up at one point. But no, it was 300k, 300 bits per second. And we actually were doing teleconferencing back then. I was doing collaborative software development
对。所以，帕特里克，你的……我记得我大概九岁的时候，有一个，我想是2400波特的调制解调器。帕特里克，你的第一次互联网体验是什么样的？我是高速冲浪。我当时用的是28k，老兄。哦，你从28k开始的。后来他们有了56k，56k有些很特别的地方。好像它有交换机什么的。他们一度升级到了56k拨号上网。不过没那回事，是300k，不对，是每秒300比特。而且我们当时其实已经在做远程会议了。我在进行协作软件开发，
with people all across the country in 1971. It's a good point. I wonder why different projects now don't do collaborative coding. I think part of it is it's hard to really develop your identity. You know, back then you probably knew everybody who was on the Internet at that point because it's a closed community. Well, you get back home pretty quickly. Yeah, right, right. You know, in 1976, I moved to Houston so my wife could postdoc and I commuted to Illinois over the net.
1971年就和全国各地的人一起。这是一个很好的观点。我想知道为什么现在的不同项目不进行协作编码。我想部分原因在于，很难真正发展出你的身份认同。你知道的，在那个时候，你可能认识互联网上的每一个人，因为这是一个封闭的社区。好吧，你的社交圈子很快就会收窄。是的，没错，没错。你知道的，在1976年，我搬到了休斯顿，为了让我妻子做博士后，而我通过网络通勤到伊利诺伊。
You know, I come back up to Illinois about every six or eight weeks, check in and go back down to Houston. And we were doing a lot. I mean, there was a lot of advanced stuff going on. Of course, you know, other people were on the net, you know, UCLA and MIT and Stanford and SRI and Utah and on and on, you know, Engelbart's NLS was on the net, which was just a mind blow. So what's NLS? Doug Engelbart invented the mouse for a system called, the online system called NLS. And it was a hypertext system in 1970 with a three-button mouse and a five-finger key set. You courted commands with the key set, and it would echo the command as soon as it was disambiguated by what you had courted that was real simple you know a thumb was a and index finger b and two of them you know c and you
你知道的，我大约每六到八周回一次伊利诺伊，打个卡然后又回休斯顿。我们当时在做很多事情。我的意思是，有很多先进的事情正在发生。当然，你知道的，其他人也在网上，你知道的，UCLA、MIT、斯坦福、SRI、犹他等等，你知道的，恩格尔巴特（Engelbart）的NLS也在网上，这简直让人大开眼界。那么，什么是NLS？道格·恩格尔巴特（Doug Engelbart）为一个系统发明了鼠标，这个在线系统被称为NLS。它是一个1970年的超文本系统，带有三键鼠标和一个五指键盘组。你用键盘组输入命令，一旦系统通过你输入的组合明确了你的意图，它就会立刻回显出命令。这非常简单，你知道的，大拇指是a，食指是b，两个一起按就是c，你知道的，
know nothing fancy and then everything was outlined for them because they were pushing it to do text, let alone figures or, you know, graphics. So everything was outlined for them. And you could do things like pick up a section and move it and all the subsections down. There were things called view specs where you could say, show me the first two lines of the first three levels of this document. Bing, it's on the screen. My favorite was NLS was coded in a language called L10
没有什么花哨的，而且所有东西都是大纲形式的，因为他们当时正极力推动它来处理文本，更不用说图表或图形了。所以一切都是大纲形式的。你可以做一些事情，比如选中一个段落并移动它，下面所有的子段落也会跟着移动。有一种叫做视图规范（view specs）的东西，你可以说：“向我展示这个文档前三个级别的头两行。”啪，它就显示在屏幕上了。我最喜欢的是，NLS是用一种叫做L10的语言编写的，
and a procedure call in L10 looked like a link to NLS. Oh, interesting. So you could do something like you're sitting there at your terminal and you could say, huh, what does that procedure do? Chord split screen, select the procedure, jump link.
而L10中的一个过程调用（procedure call）看起来就像是指向NLS的链接。哦，真有趣。所以你可以做一些事情，比如你正坐在终端前，你可以说：“嗯，那个过程是做什么的？”输入组合键分屏，选择过程，跳转链接。
You had the body of what you were looking at in the lower part of the screen and the procedure body in the top. Oh, that's cool. Yeah. This is 1970. Remember, in 1970, 99% of everybody is still on punch cards. Right, right. When did people actually really get on the internet? I think it was like the early 90s, right?
你正在看的内容的主体在屏幕下方，而过程的主体在上方。哦，太酷了。是的。这是1970年。记住，在1970年，99%的人还在使用打孔卡。对，对。人们是什么时候才真正连上互联网的？我想大概是90年代初吧，对吧？
Yeah, right. This is, yeah, this is 20 years. Yeah, exactly. Before it was opened up to the public. We did a land use management system for the six counties at Illinois. We did a land use management system for the six counties around Chicago. We had put the first tunic system on the net in the summer of 75. And then we cut it down to fit on a one board PDP-11 in a pedestal with a plasma screen and touch. This is in 76 to create an intelligent terminal that had a keyboard, but you didn't need it. And we could do graphs for land use management and figures and draw maps down to the square mile and, you know, shade them accordingly and all sorts of stuff.
对，没错。这是，是的，这比它向公众开放早了20年。我们为伊利诺伊州的六个县做了一个土地利用管理系统。我们为芝加哥周边的六个县做了一个土地利用管理系统。我们在75年夏天将第一个Tunic系统连上了网。然后在76年把它精简，以便装入一个单板PDP-11中，它带有一个带触摸功能的等离子屏幕。这是在1976年，目的是创造一个智能终端，它带有键盘，但你并不需要它。我们可以为土地利用管理绘制图表和图形，将地图精确到平方英里，你知道的，并进行相应的阴影着色等等各种事情。
Wow. Amazing. I mean, a lot of the, you know, when I look at, you know, some of the BLAS, you know, the linear algebra systems today, a lot of them still have that code. It's either Fortran or Assembly. A lot of that code that those people wrote 20 years, 30 years ago, well, what, 50 years ago now is still there. Well, yeah, that's one of the things you have to be careful about. Actually, we wrote three operating systems from scratch before 75, but they were all done in a high-level language.
哇。太惊人了。我的意思是，许多，你知道的，当我看到，你知道的，当今的一些BLAS，也就是线性代数系统时，许多系统仍然在使用那些代码。要么是Fortran，要么是汇编。那些人在20年前、30年前——好吧，现在已经是50年前了——编写的许多代码依然存在。好吧，是的，这是你必须小心的事情之一。实际上，在75年之前，我们从头编写了三个操作系统，但它们都是用高级语言完成的。
We got away from Assembler very quickly. I should have mentioned about NLS. NLS was a full hypertext system, both directions, unlike the web, which is just one way. Wait, so what do you mean by that? I didn't understand that. In the web, you have links to go forward, but you don't have links to point back into stuff. And so it's full hypertext. Oh, I see what you're saying.
我们非常迅速地摆脱了汇编语言。我应该提一下关于NLS的事情。NLS是一个双向的完整超文本系统，这与仅仅是单向的网络（Web）不同。等等，你这话是什么意思？我没听懂。在万维网中，你有向前的链接，但你没有指向其他内容的返回链接。所以它是完整的超文本。哦，我明白你的意思了。
Okay. And we were doing all of that. We did a spin out from the university, doing a lot of stuff for the DOD. Actually, yeah. Can you dive into that a little bit? So I know, you know, my advisor actually, fortunately, is after I graduated, but he did a spin off. So he went and worked for a company. And so what is that like as a professor? You know, how do you... Actually, we were never professors. We were always, we were academic staff. Ah, got it. Okay. So it's probably a different kind of a discussion than if you're a professor and you kind of leave. As I commented earlier, before we started all this,
好吧。我们当时正在做所有这些事情。我们从大学分拆出来，为国防部（DOD）做了很多事情。实际上，是的。你能深入聊聊这个吗？我知道，你知道的，我的导师实际上——幸运的是，是在我毕业之后——但他做了一个分拆项目。所以他去了一家公司工作。那么，作为一名教授，那种感觉是怎样的？你知道的，你是如何……其实我们从来都不是教授。我们一直是学术员工。啊，明白了。所以这可能和你是教授然后选择离开的情况有所不同。正如我刚才评论的那样，在我们开始这一切之前，
to give you an idea of what this group was like, and I'll repeat, was we went out to work on ILLIAC-4 once. And it was being built in Paoli, Pennsylvania. And as we got off the plane in Chicago, the flight attendant said to me kind of breathlessly, are you guys in a band? And I said, no, we're Crypto Fascist Likies of the Military Industrial Complex, which is what the student radicals called us. I just owned it. I should mention the thing about ILLIAC 4 because that was really important. All this demonstration stuff came, the whole reason for bringing up the cost overruns that were caused by TI bugging out on the chips, okay, put the head of the project under a lot of pressure from ARPA because the machine was costing a heck of a lot, a lot more than predicted.
为了让你对这个群体有个概念，我要重复一遍，我们曾经去Paoli（宾夕法尼亚州）建造ILLIAC-4。当我们走下芝加哥的飞机时，空乘人员气喘吁吁地对我说：“你们是乐队吗？”我说：“不，我们是军工复合体的法西斯走狗。”这就是学生激进分子对我们的称呼。我只是大方承认了。我应该提一下关于ILLIAC 4的事情，因为这真的很重要。所有这些示威游行，由于德州仪器在芯片问题上掉链子而导致成本超支的整个原因，好吧，这让项目负责人承受了来自ARPA的巨大压力，因为这台机器的造价高得惊人，远超预期。
And so the head of the project finally said, oh, gee, you know, I can't guarantee the safety of the machine if it comes to Illinois. See, I mean, ARPA was getting reticent about giving him more money to finish the machine. So instead, ILLIAC-4 went to NASA Ames Research Center on Moffett Field. And of course, for that guy to accept it, he said, oh, well, hey, wait a minute. I can't take this unless I have the money to finish it. Well, they always like to give money to the new guy,
所以项目负责人终于说：“哦，天哪，你知道的，如果这台机器运到伊利诺伊州，我无法保证它的安全。”看，我的意思是，ARPA开始对给他更多资金来完成这台机器感到犹豫不决。因此，ILLIAC-4转去了位于莫菲特菲尔德（Moffett Field）的NASA埃姆斯研究中心（NASA Ames Research Center）。当然，为了让那个人接受它，他说：“哦，好吧，等等。我不能接受这个，除非我有资金来完成它。”你看，他们总是喜欢给新人资金，
whereas they're reticent to give money to the old guy. Right? So the student radicals, even though there was no classified research to be done in Illinois, provided the excuse for the machine to go to Moffitt, where classified research could be done on it. Oh, okay. Okay. Kind of backfired.
而对老人则比较吝啬。对吧？所以，尽管伊利诺伊州没有机密研究要做，但学生激进分子还是为这台机器转移到莫菲特提供了借口，而机密研究恰恰可以在那里进行。哦，好吧。好吧。有点适得其反。
But the thing about Moffitt is you don't have, you're not on a college campus anymore. So now you have to try and draw folks from, I guess, Stanford would be the closest university. Well, I mean, there were lots of people wanting to do, you know, atom bomb simulations and stuff on this machine. I mean, when we turned it on, it was 13 times faster than any other machine in the world. Actually, can you dive into that? So I've heard a lot about, you know, supercomputers being used
但关于莫菲特的妙处在于，你不再处于大学校园里了。所以现在你得试着从——我猜斯坦福会是最近的大学——吸引人们来。嗯，我的意思是，有很多人想在这台机器上做原子弹模拟之类的东西。我的意思是，当我们启动它时，它的速度比世界上任何其他机器快13倍。实际上，你能深入讲讲这个吗？我听说过很多关于超级计算机被用于原子弹模拟的事情，但我其实不知道这意味着什么。所以当有人进行原子弹模拟时，他们在模拟什么？是破坏的程度吗？这里的价值在哪里？有一类问题可以用类似的方法解决。从天气到核弹，据我所能理解的，事实上，在电气工程中有一件非常简单的事情，那就是求解拉普拉斯方程，你会说，好吧，我有一个电位，比如沿着一面墙、一条线或一个轴，
for atom bomb simulations, but I don't actually know what that means. So when someone does an atom bomb simulation, what are they simulating? Is it the amount of destruction? What's the value there? There's a whole class of problems that are solved in a similar way. Everything from the weather to nuclear bombs as near as i can understand and in fact there's a very simple thing one does in electrical engineering solving la place's equation where you say okay i've got a potential say along one wall line or axis and
另一个在另一边。问题是，介于两者之间的一切的电位是多少？你要做的是针对细胞内发生的事情提出一组方程式。好吧。你有测量点。然后通过对它进行迭代插值，得出该效应应该是什么。比如看24小时的天气预报。他们把地球，你知道的，大气层分成大立方体。他们有方程式来模拟这些立方体中随着空气流动而发生的事情。
another one on the other. And the question is, what's the potential for everything in between? And what you do is you come up with a set of equations for what happens in the cell. Okay. And you have measured points. And then you interpolate by iterating over it, what that effect should be. So take the 24 hour, the weather forecast. They divide the planet, you know, the atmosphere up into big cubes. They have equations for simulating what happens in those cubes with the movement of air.
他们有该空间中某些点的测量数据。对。没错。对。所以这些事情是真实的。然后他们通过对这些数据进行迭代，说：这会对现在的气压、温度、风速等产生什么影响，它会去哪里？因此，通过对这些进行数千次的迭代，他们就得到了对天气的预测。原子弹模拟也是如此。
They have measurements for certain points in that space. Right. Yep. Right. So those things are real. And then they iterate over that saying, what effect should that have? Pressure, temperature, you know, wind speed, et cetera, of what's there now and where will it be? So by iterating over that thousands of times, they get a prediction of the weather. Same thing with an atom bomb simulation.
明白了。我明白了。所以他们会在大洋上空或者某种真正受控的环境中引爆原子弹，然后他们就可以进行插值。嗯，是的，对。或者他们把——甚至在地下——他们把所有的测量数据和一切都记录下来，然后，好吧，实际上，正如你所说，进行一次实地测试，获取所有测量数据。现在你可以把它输入进去，改变强度和一切，看看会发生什么。明白了。这有点像是一个过渡，但如今，这仍然是，
Got it. I see. So they detonate atom bombs over the ocean or like in some kind of a really controlled environment and then they can interpolate. Well, yeah, right. Or they take the, even underground, they take all the measurements and everything and then, well, actually, as you say, do one live, take all the measurements. Now you can plug it in and vary strength and everything and see what happens. Got it. It's kind of a segue, but nowadays, is that still the, the,
你知道的，你仍然会时不时看到，“哦，你知道的，我们有了一台新的超级计算机。我想Nvidia造了一台。”然后其他地方还有别人。那些是什么，超级计算机在今天有什么用？嗯，用途太多了。我的意思是，注意一下天气预报变得准了多少。说得好。好吧。
you know, like you still see every now and then like, Oh, you know, we have a new supercomputer. I think Nvidia built one. And then there's someone somewhere else. What are those like, what are supercom know, we have a new supercomputer. I think NVIDIA built one and then there's someone somewhere else. What are those, like, what are supercomputers used for today? Well, tons of things. I mean, notice how much better the weather forecasts are. Good point. Okay.
你知道的，而且这些模型无疑变得更加复杂了。我的意思是，你知道的，我做网络已经很久了。我很久没有碰过那些东西了。倒也是。是的。但是，你知道的，只要看一看，你就会发现蛋白质折叠，你知道的。对，对。你知道的，各种各样的事情都在用那种问题来做，你知道的。不管怎样。是的，这说得通。总之，事情伴随着ARPANET持续了很长时间。我们做了，你知道的，所有你能想到的基础协议。而且我必须说，你真正需要考虑的事情之一是，请记住，ARPANET被构建为一个资源共享网络。
You know, and also the models have undoubtedly gotten a lot more sophisticated. I mean, you know, I've been a network guy for a long time now. I haven't been near any of that stuff for quite a while. Fair enough. Yeah. But, you know, just looking at it, you can see protein folding, you know. Right, right. You know, all sorts of things are being done, you know, with those sorts of problems, you know. Anyway. Yeah, that makes sense. So anyway, things went along with the ARPANET for a long time. We did, you know, all the base protocols that you would think about. And I have to say, one of the things you really want to take into account is, remember, the ARPANET was built to be a resource sharing network.
它的建立是为了降低在ARPA项目上做研究的成本。好吧。这样他们就不必为网上的每个站点或他们资助的每个站点都购买一台庞大的计算机了。而且，很快这就变成了，你知道的，非常符合我们的工作方式。事实上，我们是英国卢瑟福高能实验室（Rutherford High Energy Lab）大型IBM 360/95的最大用户，因为我们当时正非法地将文件从CERN传输到卢瑟福，再传到伊利诺伊，这样它们就可以用来建造巴达维亚（Batavia）。那么什么是巴达维亚？费米实验室（Fermilab）。哦，有趣。好的。
It was built to lower the cost of doing research on ARPA projects. Okay. So that they wouldn't have to buy a big honking computer for every site on the net or every site they were funding. And, and very quickly that became, you know, very much our, our, our way of working. In fact, we were the largest user of the big use 36095 at the Rutherford High Energy Lab in the UK because we were illegally moving files from CERN to Rutherford to Illinois so they could be used to build Batavia. So what's Batavia? Fermilab. Oh, interesting. Okay.
所有这些都在同时发生。啊，酷。而且，你知道的，有很多合作正在进行。大约在那个时候，事实上，很快，也就是1970年、1971年，一个法国人来到了美国。他的名叫路易斯·普森（Louis Poussin）。他曾在MAC项目工作过，该项目构建了Unix的前身Multics。当他在那里做博士后时，他发明了一项你可能听说过的东西，叫做shell。他曾致力于这方面的工作。所以他回来考察ARPA网。
All that was going on at the same time. Ah, cool. And, you know, there was a lot of collaboration going on. Now, around that time, in fact, very soon, in fact, 1970, 71, a guy came over from France. His name was Louis Poussin. He had been on Project Mac, which had built Maltics, which is the precursor to Unix. And while he was there as a postdoc, he invented something you might have heard of called a shell. He had worked on that. And so he came back to look at the ARPA net.
他非常感兴趣。他决定回到巴黎的INRIA，建立一个网络来做网络研究，这并不是——你知道的，ARPA对那不感兴趣。所以他们回去了并开始着手研究。当然，他们做的事情，正如任何人所应该做的那样，基本上是从零开始。你知道的，他们和BBN谈过，谈到了IMP（接口信息处理机）是如何工作的以及所有的考虑因素。事实上，IMP小组中负责构建交换机的负责人之一，曾在INRIA与他们呆了一段时间来研究这个。但他们是从零开始的。他们说：我们要做出什么最小的一组假设，才能拥有一个能工作的网络？
He was very intrigued. And he decided to go back to Paris, into area, and build a network to do research on networks, which is not what, you know, ARPA wasn't interested in that. So they went back and started to work on it. And, of course, what they did, as anybody should, they essentially started out clean. You know, they'd talked with BBN and they talked about how the IMPs worked and all the considerations they went in. And, in fact, one of the guys who was in charge of the I imp group, building the switches, spent some time with them at ARIA working on that. But they started off clean. They said, what are the minimal set of assumptions we have to make to have a network that works?
这个想法是提出一组最小的假设，然后看看还需要什么。好吧？是的，这很有看看还需要什么。好吧？是的，这很有意义。完全正确。所以他们想出的第一件事就是数据报。你知道的，其他所有人立刻陷入了这样一种思维定式：好吧，你知道的，这就像电话系统，我们必须有这些电路，
The idea was come up with a minimal set of assumptions and then see what else was needed. Okay? Yeah, that makes see what else was needed. Okay? Yeah, that makes sense. Right, absolutely. And so what they came up with was the first thing they came up with was the datagram. You know, everybody else immediately sort of fell into, well, you know, it's like the phone system, and we've got to have these circuits,
数据包必须遵循，事情必须遵循这些路径。而ARPANET是第一个分组交换网络。1960年，保罗·巴兰（Paul Baran）写了一系列关于分组交换的报告。而ARPANET是第一个真正将其实现的网络。那么，什么是分组交换呢？嗯，在此之前，我们有语音网络。而在1960年，巴兰对数据网络进行了这项研究。军方曾建立了一种叫做报文交换（message switching）的网络，整个报文——通常更像是一个文件——
and packets have to follow, and things have to follow these paths. And now the ARPANET was the first packet switching network. In 1960, Paul Buran had written a series of reports on packet switching. And the ARPANET was the first one to actually realize it. Now, what is packet switching? Well, before this, we had voice networks. And in 1960, Buran did this study on data networks. And the military had built something called the message switching network, where the whole message, usually it was more like a file,
在计算机之间完整地移动。巴兰提出了这样一个想法：不，让我们把事情分解成小块，在网络中发送这些小块。他的观点是，语音流量是连续的，语音连接需要很长时间。它们很长。数据通常是突发性的。你会发送一些东西，然后等上一分钟，再发送一些东西，你知道的，来回交替，连接是短暂的，所以拥有一个专门为数据构建的网络，并且交换小型
was moved intact from computer to computer. Buran had the idea of, no, let's break things up into small pieces and send those around the network. And his point was that voice traffic was continuous and voice connections took a long time. They were long. Data was usually bursting. You'd send some stuff and you wait a minute and you send some stuff and you know back and forth and the connections were short short lived and so it'd be good to have a network that was just built for data and it switched small
数据包会很好。所以当你提到“交换”时，这个动词你是怎么用的？因为这是我有点困惑的地方。嗯，好的。你可以让每个主机都连接到其他所有主机，但这需要大量的电线。对，对。就像N平方什么的，对吧？就像N平方，对吧。完全正确。所以让我们指定一些机器专门用来做转发。
packets so when you say switched what does that how are you using that verb? Because that's what I'm a little confused on. Well, okay. You could have every host connected to every other host, but that would take a lot of wires. Right, right. Like N squared or something, right? Like N squared, right. Exactly. So let's dedicate some machines to just doing relay.
我们不需要那么多电线。并不是每个人使用每台机器的频率都一样。不仅如此，我们还可以获得容错能力。到达同一个地方，我们有不止一条路径。对。到达同一个地方不止一条路径，对吧？但即使在当时，普遍的想法仍然是：嗯，如果我打开一个连接，那么所有的数据包都会沿着这个连接走。普森的小组将他们的网络命名为Ciclod，他们说：不，不，不，不要做这种假设，至少一开始不要。让我们假设每个数据包都是独立交换的，它们可以走它们想要的任何路径。现在，我一直认为单凭分组交换并不是一个激进的想法。而且实际上，
We don't need as many wires. Not everybody is using every machine the same amount. And not only that, but we can pick up resiliency. We have more than one path to the same place. Right. them one path to the same place, right? But the general idea even then was, well, but if I open up a connection, then all the packets just follow that connection. Puzan's group, which called their network Ciclod, said, no, no, no, let's not assume that, at least not to start with. Let's assume that every packet is switched independently and that they could be any way they want. Now, I've always said that packet switching alone was not a radical idea. And actually,
这取决于——对某些人来说是，但这也取决于你的年龄。如果你的成型期是在电话通信时代度过的，那么把数据分解成小数据包并通过网络发送的想法就是一个激进的想法。如果你的成型期稍晚一点，是在计算机时代，这算什么大不了的？对吧。你们想互相交流。我把这些东西放在缓冲区里，你知道的？好吧，我拿起缓冲区发送出去。那又怎样？对。这是显而易见的事情。是的。这说得通。所以这就像是两个学科的结合，就像两个不同的学科走到了一起。
it depends on, to some it was, but it depends on how old you were. If your formative years had been with telephony, then the idea of breaking packets, breaking data up into small packets and sending them through the network was a radical idea. If your formative years were just a little bit later with computers, what's the big deal? Right. You want to talk to each other. I got this stuff in a buffer, you know? Okay. I pick up the buffer and send it. So what? Right. It's the obvious thing to do. Yeah. That makes sense. So it's like a union of two disciplines, like two different disciplines are coming together.
完全正确。所以，但是普森出现后说：嗯，等等。为什么每个数据包必须遵循相同的路径？让我们把它变成随机的。你知道的，让我们做得更好。如果我们把事情散开，用随机的方式去做，我们就能更好地利用资源。然后他们退一步说：嗯，等等。不管我们的网络做得有多好，主机是不会信任我们的。
Exactly. And so, but Pazan comes along and says, well, wait a minute. Why does every packet have to follow the same path? Let's make it stochastic. You know, let's make it better. We can better utilize the resources if we spread things out, do it stochastically. And then they step back and they said, well, wait a minute. No matter how good we do the network, the hosts are not going to trust us.
它们会进行检查，以确保它们收到了发送出去的全部内容。因此，网络不必是完美的。对。它只需要做到尽力而为（best effort）。如果我们能在主机之间建立一个可靠的端到端协议，网络虽然不能什么都不做，但它不需要做到完美。没错。我不知道现在在Zoom或其他视频会议中是否还能做到这一点，
They're going to check and make sure they get everything they sent. Therefore, the network doesn't have to be perfect. Right. It just has to make a best effort. If we have a reliable protocol end-to-end between the hosts, the network doesn't have to do nothing, but it doesn't have to be perfect. That's right. I don't know if it's possible to do this nowadays in Zoom or these other video conferencing,
但当我们以前玩电子游戏时，曾经有一种方法——现在可能还有——你可以按下一个键来查看丢包率。所以在你玩游戏时，如果你连接良好，它可能会在0%和1%之间波动。绝对有那么一些时候，我确信是我们自己家里出了问题，我们的丢包率接近10%。但游戏依然能正常运行。所以，是的。我确信是我们自己家里出了问题，我们的丢包率接近10%，
but when we used to play video games, there used to be a way, it probably still is, where you could hit a key and see the packet loss. And so while you're playing, if you have a good connection, you might oscillate between 0% and 1%. There were definitely times where I'm sure it was problems in our own house where we were approaching like 10% packet loss. And the game still worked. So yeah. sure it was problems in our own house where we were approaching like 10 packet loss and uh you know the game still worked so so uh so yeah and in fact you could actually be better at the game
你知道的，游戏依然能正常运行。所以，所以，是的，事实上你甚至可以玩得更好，
because you would kind of teleport around well you know that that's another thing where um well yeah so and in fact it was the it was the ciclod guysiclod is named after a group of Greek islands that in ancient times had decentralized organization and would come together for common defense and things like that. Oh, interesting. Ciclod was focusing on the decentralization and the switches in Ciclod were called Cigal, which is grasshopper in France, in French.
因为你会有点像瞬间移动一样。好吧，你知道的，那是另一回事，嗯，是的。事实上，这就是Ciclod团队——Ciclod是以希腊的一组岛屿命名的，在古代，这些岛屿具有分散的组织形式，为了共同防御等目的聚在一起。哦，有趣。Ciclod专注于去中心化，Ciclod中的交换机被称为Cigal，在法语中是“蚱蜢”的意思。
Ah, okay. Okay. And so they're the ones who came up with the basic layer structure that you heard, you've always heard, you know, physical data link network transport. And the idea was in those days, because, you know, leased lines were pretty flaky, especially in France.
啊，好吧。好吧。所以他们是提出你一直听到的基本分层结构的人，你知道的，物理层、数据链路层、网络层、传输层。当时的理念是，因为你知道的，专线相当不可靠，尤其是在法国。
So they were running a fairly reliable protocol at the bottom between, between the switches. Okay. That meant that the only thing that reason for loss in the network layer where they were relaying was due to either congestion or bit errors during relay. You know, they can protect the packets from on the wire. But once they were in the machine, it didn't happen very often, but you know, you could pick up a memory error. Right. So that's what they were looking for. So they, but you know, but it's the old 80 20 rule, right? It's easy to get more,
所以在底部，也就是交换机之间，他们运行着一个相当可靠的协议。这意味着在进行转发的网络层中，丢包的唯一原因要么是拥塞，要么是转发过程中的比特错误。你知道的，他们可以保护网线上的数据包。但一旦它们进入机器，这种情况虽然不常发生，但你知道的，你可能会遇到内存错误。对。所以这就是他们寻找的东西。所以他们，但你知道的，这就是古老的80/20法则，对吧？获取更多内容很容易，
maybe 90 90 10 rule or whatever you want to call it. You know, it's easy to get those first 90% of the errors, but those last 10 are hard. We'll let the host deal with that. They're pretty rare anyway, so we'll just deal with those higher up. That makes sense. Actually, a bit of a segue here, but I was really curious. I want to make sure I didn't lose track of it. The machines, even today, when I send a packet to Netflix or something, it hops among all these machines.
也许是90/10法则，随便你怎么称呼它。你知道的，要解决前90%的错误很容易，但最后10%很难。我们把这些留给主机去处理。反正它们也很罕见，所以我们就在高层处理它们。这说得通。其实，这里算是一个小插曲，但我真的很好奇。我想确保我没有忘掉这一点。即使在今天，当我向Netflix或什么地方发送数据包时，它也会在所有这些机器之间跳转。
We'll definitely dive into that. But one thing I want to know off the bat is, like, who actually programs those machines? Like, who's responsible for them today? The guy you buy your routers from. So, like, so, well, my router came from, oh, buy the router. So we have, like, a Netgear. So Netgear is actually working on the internet backbone or how does that work? Well, they work on those routers.
我们绝对会深入探讨这一点。但我首先想知道的一件事是，比如，到底是谁在对这些机器进行编程？比如，今天是谁在负责它们？你从谁那里买路由器，就是谁。所以，比如，嗯，我的路由器来自，哦，买路由器。所以我们有，比如Netgear（网件）。所以Netgear实际上在参与互联网骨干网的工作，还是说那是怎么运作的？嗯，他们致力于那些路由器。
I mean, you know, the size of routers that are used in the actual backbone or in the periphery are all different sized, you know, Cisco, Juniper, you know, whatever routers. But like who defines the policy, I guess, is what I'm asking.
我的意思是，你知道的，实际骨干网或外围设备中使用的路由器的大小是各种尺寸都有的，你知道的，思科（Cisco）、瞻博网络（Juniper），不管是什么路由器。但我想问的是，谁来定义策略？
Who actually decides this packet should go here, this packet's a higher priority? There are standards for that. Okay, got it. And that we deal with at various levels for various kinds of routing. Okay, interesting. We'll get back to that. But they came up
到底是谁决定这个数据包应该去这里，这个数据包的优先级更高？这方面是有标准的。哦，明白了。我们在各个级别针对各种路由处理这些。哦，有趣。我们会回到这个话题。但他们提出了
with this whole idea of a best effort network of these basic layers that the bottom layer did some error control. In their case, it happened to be reliable, but in later cases, we were able to relax that because the media got better. And then end to end for the best, you know, transport to correct the errors that were lost by the network. What was interesting and was, okay, I should first admit something. I'm currently working with Puzan. He had his 91st birthday a few weeks ago. Oh, wow. Congrats to them. And well, actually, I had also, Louis was the guy, the big wig, the guy who was in charge of everything.
通过这种关于这些基本层的尽力而为网络的整个理念，底层做了一些差错控制。在他们的情况下，它恰好是可靠的，但在后来的情况下，我们能够放宽这一要求，因为媒体变好了。然后通过端到端来进行最佳的（你知道的）传输，以纠正被网络丢失的差错。有趣的是，而且，好吧，我应该先承认一件事。我目前正在和 Puzan 一起工作。他几周前刚过完91岁生日。哦，哇。祝贺他们。而且，实际上，我也曾，Louis 是那个家伙，那个大人物，负责所有事情的人。
So he's only, he and I have only gotten to know each other pretty well lately, but back then all of his guys were my age. So they were all, I became really good friends with all of them. They, these guys had come up with this new way of looking at things just based on what they had seen. Right. What were the minimal assumptions that got us to do this? And then they stepped back and said, okay, that's the minimal assumptions. What else do we need? And the answer was nothing nothing it was a mind blow
所以他，他和我也只是最近才相当熟悉，但那时候他的所有手下都和我同龄。所以他们全都是，我和他们所有人都成了非常好的朋友。他们，这些家伙根据他们所看到的情况，想出了这种看待事物的新方式。对吧。让我们走到这一步的最小假设是什么？然后他们退一步说，好吧，这就是最小假设。我们还需什么？答案是：什么都不需要，什么都不需要。这太震撼了。
you know i mean this was far simpler than what everyone else was doing yeah that is like uh some of the most amazing uh experiences that i've had professionally have been where we've been able to build something just extremely elegant. I mean, the thing that's coming to my mind is when we worked on AutoGrad, like numeric differentiation. And so you used to have to, if you're doing some kind of machine learning thing, you used to have to define all of the partial derivatives yourself. And there's a lot of functions that have no closed form. And so you're just not didn't use those functions.
你知道我的意思是，这比其他所有人正在做的事情要简单得多。是的，这就像……呃，我职业生涯中有一些最令人惊叹的……呃，经历，就是我们能够构建出极其优雅的东西。我的意思是，我脑子里浮现的一件事是我们在研究 AutoGrad 的时候，比如数值微分。所以以前，如果你在做某种机器学习的事情，你必须自己定义所有的偏导数。而且有很多函数是没有解析解的。所以你干脆不使用那些函数。
You know, and then and then we came up with, you know, numerical autograd, which was which was in some stable algorithms there. And so, yeah, and then the answer became, well, you can you can differentiate through just about anything. I mean, like you might empirically have issues, but from an academic standpoint, it kind of blew the whole field wide open. And so those are some of the most powerful moments when you realize, oh, I bought, I boiled it down to these three or four components and we're actually done here. Absolutely. It is such a high when, you know, it all comes together. And actually, I should back up a long way. When we were working on ILLIAC 4, ILLIAC 4 wasn't terribly interesting, but we had access to probably the finestroughs 5500. Probably no one in the audience has ever heard one, seen one. But it was the most elegant machine I have ever worked on. There were no special cases.
你知道的，然后，然后我们想出了，你知道的，数值自动微分，其中包含了一些稳定的算法。所以，是的，然后答案变成了，好吧，你几乎可以通过任何东西进行求导。我的意思是，你可能在经验上遇到问题，但从学术角度来看，它基本上把整个领域彻底打开了。所以，当意识到“哦，我把它归结为这三四个组件，我们其实就大功告成了”时，那些就是最具力量的时刻。绝对是这样的。当你知道这一切都水到渠成时，那种感觉真是太棒了。实际上，我应该把时间线往前推很久。当我们在研究 ILLIAC 4 时，ILLIAC 4 并不是特别有趣，但我们可以使用可能最好的 Burroughs 5500。可能听众里没有人听说过或见过它。但它是我共事过的最优雅的机器。没有特例。
If you knew how A worked and B worked, you could guess what C would do and you'd be right. That's nice. This machine was built in 1964, even before my time. And it was the first machine to use a stack for procedure entry. The lowest level machine, the lowest level language on the machine was ALGOL. There was no assembler. There were no general purpose registers. Every register had a purpose and it was used for that and that alone.
如果你知道 A 是怎么工作的，B 是怎么工作的，你就能猜出 C 会做什么，而且你会猜对。真不错。这台机器制造于1964年，甚至在我那个时代之前。它是第一台在程序入口使用栈的机器。机器上的最低级语言是 ALGOL。没有汇编器。没有通用寄存器。每个寄存器都有一个用途，它只用于那个用途，别无其他。
The operating system was written in an extension of ALGOL called SPAL. I mean, it was a paging descriptor machine tagged architecture. As near as I can tell, this machine in 1964 was secure. If you indexed off the end of an array, it was a fault. The stack was tagged non-executable. You couldn't overwrite it. Oh, that's nice. Okay. Arrays were descriptor-based, so you had tight control over it. The machine was incredible. One of the little ones that I always tell people about, because it shows the power of architecture. You know what a floating point number looks like, right? You have sine, exponent,
操作系统是用 ALGOL 的一个扩展编写的，叫做 SPAL。我的意思是，它是一台分页描述符机器，采用了标签架构。据我所能了解到的，这台机器在1964年就是安全的。如果你索引越过了数组的末尾，就会发生故障。栈被标记为不可执行。你无法覆盖它。哦，这真不错。好吧。数组是基于描述符的，所以你可以对它进行严格的控制。这台机器太不可思议了。我总是跟别人讲的一个小例子，因为它展示了架构的力量。你知道浮点数长什么样，对吧？你有符号位、指数……
mantissa. And we always put the decimal point between the exponent and the mantissa. They put it at the right end of the word. They put the decimal point at the right end of the word? Yep. But there is no... So, okay, Patrick will probably help me out here a lot. But as far as I understand with floating point, right, you have a bit for the sign, right? You have the exponent, which is a tiny integer, right?
尾数。我们总是把小数点放在指数和尾数之间。他们把它放在了字（word）的最右端。他们把小数点放在了字的最右端？是的。但没有……所以，好吧，帕特里克（Patrick）在这里可能会给我很多帮助。但据我所理解的浮点数，对吧，你有一个符号位，对吧？你有一个指数，它是一个很小的整数，对吧？
And then you have the mantissa. So there's not actually a decimal. I don't quite understand. You have a binary point that goes between the exponent and mantissa, right? So the whole thing is a fraction. An implicit one, yeah. Yeah. Well, there's a binary point that goes between the exponent and the mantis, right? So the whole thing is a fraction. An implicit one, yeah. Yeah. Right, right.
然后你有一个尾数。所以实际上并没有一个十进制小数点。我不太明白。在指数和尾数之间有一个二进制小数点，对吧？所以整个东西是一个分数。一个隐含的1，对吧。是的。嗯，在指数和尾数之间有一个二进制小数点，对吧？所以整个东西是一个分数。一个隐含的1，对吧。是的。没错，没错。
They put it at the right end. The reason was that on that machine, integers were unnormalized floating point numbers. They took the two separate. There was no integer to real conversion on the machine they made it they made it into one case that handled both now they had help they had a 48 oh i see okay but by just moving the point where the fraction was they changed the whole thing. So you're saying they put the exponent on the far right? Yep. And so then...
他们把它放在了最右端。原因是在那台机器上，整数是未归一化的浮点数。他们把这两个分开了。那台机器上没有整数到实数的转换，他们把它做成了一个能处理这两种情况的单一情况。当然他们有帮手，他们有一个48位——哦，我明白了，好吧。但仅仅通过移动小数所在的位置，他们就改变了整个事情。所以你是说他们把指数放在最右边？是的。所以然后……
No, it was still the same thing. Sine, exponent, mantissa. Right. Instead of having it normalized so the first bit of the mantissa was a one and a fraction, the binary point was at the right end of the mantissa was a one and a fraction. The point, the binary point was at the right end of the word and the exponent was scaled appropriately. Oh, OK. I think I get it. So you're saying the. So the. Yes. An integer is an unnormalized leading leading zeros in the mantissa.
不，它仍然是一样的东西。符号、指数、尾数。对。它不是被归一化得尾数的第一位是1和一个小数，而是二进制小数点在尾数的右端，二进制小数点在字的最右端，并且指数进行了适当的缩放。哦，好吧。我想我明白了。所以你是说……所以……是的。整数是一个带有前导零的未归一化尾数。
Yeah, that makes sense. But it was a nice, elegant solution. You don't have to worry about what's an integer and what's a real. Yeah, that makes sense. If you multiply and it gets too big, it floats. If you divide and there's a fraction left over, it floats. Ah, I see. But the whole machine was like that. Everything just
是的，这说得通。但这是一个很好的、优雅的解决方案。你不用担心什么是整数，什么是实数。是的，这说得通。如果你相乘并且它变得太大，它就浮点化。如果你相除并且有余数剩下，它就浮点化。啊，我明白了。但整台机器都是这样的。每件事都……
worked. Okay? There were no special cases. The only difference between spawning a process and a procedure call was what it returned to. Procedure call returned within the same stack.
能行。好吧？没有特例。催生一个进程和一个过程调用之间唯一的不同是它们返回的目标。过程调用返回到同一个栈。
A process returned to a different stack. Oh, that makes sense. Yep, yep. I remember when I saw, somewhat similar, when I saw a gRPC, and Patrick can kind of like echo this, but when I saw gRPC, which is this thing where you kind of define
一个进程返回到一个不同的栈。哦，这说得通。是的，是的。我记得当我看到……有点类似，当我看到 gRPC 时，帕特里克可以对此附和一下，但当我看到 gRPC 时，这是一个东西，你在其中定义……
a client and a server in this third uh this this idl and then it generates code in like a zillion different languages and then you can say okay call this function in i don't know python and then and then you do have to put the location of the machine and then in c plus plus you just say look i'm waiting you know i'm waiting for this function to get called and here is the answer. And it all just kind of was like, now I'm calling functions and getting answers. That was just this really beautiful, kind of elegant thing. And so when you see something like that, it kind of warms your heart.
客户端和服务器，在这个第三方的……这个 IDL 中，然后它会生成一吨不同语言的代码，然后你可以说，好吧，在……我不知道，比如 Python 中调用这个函数，然后……然后你必须放入机器的位置，接着在 C++ 中，你只需要说，看，我在等待（你知道的），我在等待这个函数被调用，这就是答案。这一切给人的感觉就像是，现在我在调用函数并得到答案。那真的是一种非常美丽、非常优雅的东西。所以当你看到这样的东西时，它会让你的内心感到温暖。
So anyway, so we were going along with all this stuff and, you know, Ciclod was adopted. But the ARPANET had made a couple of mistakes. Not big ones, but little ones. Well, actually, they were sort of little. Very early on, we realized that what we were, you know, operating systems were our guide. You know, we essentially, you know, operating systems were our guide. You know, we essentially, you know, we're emulating an operating system on the net, on the ARPANET.
总之，所以我们一直在推进所有这些事情，你知道的，Ciclod 被采纳了。但是 ARPANET 犯了几个错误。不是大错误，但却是小错误。嗯，实际上，它们算是小错误。很早的时候，我们就意识到我们正在（你知道的）——操作系统是我们的向导。你知道的，我们本质上（你知道的）——操作系统是我们的向导。你知道的，我们本质上（你知道的），我们在网上传真（模拟）一个操作系统，在 ARPANET 上。
And to give you an example, I mean, you will read in textbooks that Telnet is a remote login protocol. And you may have thought about it that way. Yeah, I mean, it takes an IP address and then gives you a shell on that computer. No, it's not. Telnet is a terminal driver protocol. It is the terminal driver for a network virtual terminal. Okay. So there's no difference between a terminal directly connected to the machine and one coming in over the net. Yeah, I see what you're saying. Yeah. Right. Okay. Most people will tell you, in fact, I've seen it in textbooks. Oh, it's a remote login protocol. No, not.
举个例子，我的意思是，你会在教科书中读到 Telnet 是一个远程登录协议。你可能也是这么想的。是的，我的意思是，它获取一个 IP 地址，然后在那台计算机上给你一个 Shell。不，不是的。Telnet 是一个终端驱动程序协议。它是网络虚拟终端的终端驱动程序。好吧。所以直接连接到机器的终端和通过网络进来的终端之间没有区别。是的，我明白你的意思了。是的。没错。好吧。大多数人会告诉你，事实上我在教科书中见过，哦，它是一个远程登录协议。不，不是的。
Okay. And so our whole thing was, let's have the services we have on an operating system on the net. So we had Telnet and FTP in that. Now, we also understood that addressing sort of had to follow what operating systems did. And we'd have to have application names and network addresses and all that stuff. In fact, John Shock at Xerox PARC had a very elegant way of putting it that application names tell you what you want to talk to. Network addresses tell you where they are. And routes are how to get there. Okay.
好吧。所以我们的全部宗旨是，让我们把我们在操作系统上拥有的服务搬到网上。所以我们在那上面有了 Telnet 和 FTP。现在，我们也理解寻址在某种程度上必须遵循操作系统的做法。我们必须有应用程序名和网络地址以及所有这些东西。事实上，施乐帕罗阿尔托研究中心（Xerox PARC）的约翰·肖克（John Shock）有一个非常优雅的说法：应用程序名告诉你你想和谁对话。网络地址告诉你他们在哪里。而路由则是如何到达那里。好吧。
So the plan at the beginning was you would go to like, just use an example, you know, google.com colon Google, and that would access the Google application. I mean, maybe not colon, but that would, let's back up. We're not that far along yet. Okay. One mistake we made and we discovered it pretty early was that when I said my address was 12, in the early days, the ARPANET switches, the amps, could only handle one host. And your host number was your amp port number. And that was common back then.
所以最初的计划是，你会去……比方说，举个例子（你知道的），google.com 冒号 Google，那将访问 Google 应用程序。我的意思是，也许不是冒号，但那会……让我们退一步。我们还没进展到那么远。好吧。我们犯的一个错误，并且我们很早就发现了，那就是当我说我的地址是 12 时，在早期，ARPANET 交换机（即 IMP）只能处理一个主机。而你的主机号就是你的 IMP 端口号。这在当时很常见。
Terminal numbers were often the same as the ports off the switches or concentrators they were connected to. Your telephone number, the last four digits of your telephone number were the name of the wire coming from the central office. This was common. Winter of 1972, my boss came in to work one day and said, hey, take your Air Force bases, join the net, and they're taking us at our word and they want two connections to the network. And I said, oh yeah, great shit. That's not going to work. You know, and it was pretty obvious why, because if, if you connected it to two different imps, it had two host addresses and to the network that looked like two hosts. The network didn't know those hosts went to the same place. Right.
终端号通常与它们所连接的交换机或集中器的端口相同。你的电话号码，你电话号码的最后四位数字就是来自中心局的电缆的名称。这是很常见的。1972年冬天，我的老板有一天走进办公室说：“嘿，把你们的空军基地连接到网络上，他们当真了，他们想要到网络的两个连接。”我说：“哦，耶，真他妈棒。那行不通。”你知道的，原因很明显，因为如果你把它连接到两个不同的 IMP，它就有两个主机地址，对于网络来说，这看起来像两个主机。网络并不知道这两个主机通往同一个地方。对吧。
Well, a second after I said, oh, crap, it's not going to work. I said, oh, I'm an OS guy. I've seen this problem before. I know how to fix this. We have to route to the node, not the address. Right, right. Right. We have to route all the way to the node, not the address. Right, right. Right? We have to go out all the way to the end.
好吧，在我说“哦，糟了，这行不通”之后的一秒钟，我说：“哦，我是一个操作系统人员。我以前见过这个问题。我知道怎么解决这个。我们必须路由到节点，而不是地址。对，对，对。我们必须一直路由到节点，而不是地址。对，对，对？”我们必须一直路由到终点。
The internet never fixed it. An IP address still names the interface. I'm going to jump in here and interrupt our interview today to talk about our sponsor, Zencastr. Zencastr is an all-in-one podcast production suite that gives you studio-quality audio and video without needing all that technical know-how. It records each guest locally and uploads the crystal-clear audio and video right into the suite, so you have high-quality raw materials to work with. Jason and I have been using Zencastr for programming Throwdown
互联网从来没有解决这个问题。IP 地址仍然在命名接口。我要插话打断我们今天的采访，来谈谈我们的赞助商 Zencastr。Zencastr 是一个一体化的播客制作套件，它为你提供演播室品质的音频和视频，而无需所有这些技术知识。它在本地录制每个嘉宾的音频，并将晶莹剔透的音视频直接上传到套件中，这样你就有高质量的原始素材可以处理。杰森（Jason）和我一直在为编程脱口秀（Programming Throwdown）使用 Zencastr……
for a while now, and it's a huge upgrade over the way we used to do things. It's so much easier and more seamless to have everybody join a Zencastr room and get individual audio streams for each participant, which allows editing and mastering to go much more quickly. It just also feels like a better experience for all involved. I'm so happy that we have this new solution instead of the way we used to do things back when we first started. If you would like to try Zencastr to make your own podcast, you can get a free trial by going to zen.ai slash programming throwdown. That's zen.ai slash programmingthrowdown. Back to the podcast. Wait, let me think about this.
有一段时间了，与我们过去做事的方式相比，这是一个巨大的升级。让每个人都加入一个 Zencastr 房间，并获得每个参与者的独立音频流，要容易得多、顺畅得多，这使得剪辑和母带制作能够更快地进行。对于所有相关人员来说，这也感觉像是一个更好的体验。我很高兴我们有了这个新解决方案，而不是我们刚开始时使用的那种老方法。如果你想尝试使用 Zencastr 来制作你自己的播客，你可以通过访问 zen.ai/programmingthrowdown 来获得免费试用。这就是 zen.ai/programmingthrowdown。回到播客。等等，让我想想这个。
Hang on. So an IP address. So I thought that you need the IP address and the port. Oh, no, no, no. Let's not get ahead of ourselves. Oh, no, you're right. So the interface, like the NIC, can serve multiple ports. So you're saying the IP address points to the NIC card.
等一下。所以一个 IP 地址。所以我以为你需要 IP 地址和端口。哦，不，不，不。我们不要操之过急。哦，不，你是对的。所以这个接口，比如网卡（NIC），可以服务多个端口。所以你是说 IP 地址指向网卡。
And so, yeah, so if you have like a wired connection and Wi-Fi. You have multiple NICs, you have multiple IP addresses. Right, right. That makes sense. Yep. So if you have multiple IP addresses, what's the problem with that? Like, what's the problem with you thinking that that client has two hosts and just, you know, depending on which one reaches you, you just reach back? If I have sent a packet to address A and it goes down, the network doesn't know how to route it to B at the same time. Oh, got it.
所以，是的，如果你同时有有线连接和无线 Wi-Fi。你有多个网卡，你有多个 IP 地址。对，对。这说得通。是的。所以如果你有多个 IP 地址，这有什么问题呢？比如，你认为那个客户端有两个主机，然后（你知道的）根据哪一个联系到你，你就回连过去，这有什么问题吗？如果我向地址 A 发送了一个数据包，而它宕机了，网络并不知道如何同时将其路由到 B。哦，明白了。
Got it, got it, got it. Okay, yeah, totally makes sense, yeah. Now, the next thing we did was, well, we all knew we had to have application names and all that. But, you know, after they got the network installed, man, it was like, hey, we got to have a demo. We got to show people this thing's useful. Right?
明白了，明白了，明白了。好吧，是的，完全说得通，是的。现在，我们做的下一件事是——好吧，我们都知道我们必须有应用程序名之类的东西。但是，（你知道的）在他们安装好网络之后，天哪，就像是：嘿，我们必须做一个演示。我们得向人们展示这东西是有用的。对吧？
I mean, you go, you know, we spent a lot of money doing this. So we said, okay, we don't have time to do a directory. Okay. All right. We've all got the same applications. As a stopgap, we'll put Telnet on socket one, FTP on socket three, and RJE on socket five. We have well-known ports. Two or three years later, we rewrote the Telnet spec and put it on socket 23 for testing.
我的意思是，你去（你知道的），我们花了很多钱来做这件事。所以我们说，好吧，我们没有时间做一个目录。好吧。好吧。我们都有相同的应用程序。作为权宜之计，我们将 Telnet 放在套接字 1 上，FTP 放在套接字 3 上，RJE 放在套接字 5 上。我们有知名端口（well-known ports）。两三年后，我们重写了 Telnet 规范，并把它放在套接字 23 上用于测试。
It's still there. Yeah. Yeah, for people who don't know, when you Telnet to a host, you don't have to specify the port. I mean, it's true for almost anything, right? If you go to a website, you don't have to specify the port i mean it's true for almost anything right if you go to a website you don't have to specify the port you know there's defaults no you do have to specify the port uh well if you go like let's say just in your browser and you type google.com you don't talk you don't do it but the browser does yeah but the the browser has a default like by default it'll connect to what is it 80 i think, I think, right? Yeah, port 80, right. And so you can go on Wikipedia and see a list
它现在还在那儿。是的。是的，对于不知道的人来说，当你 Telnet 到一个主机时，你不需要指定端口。我的意思是，几乎对任何东西都是如此，对吧？如果你去一个网站，你不需要指定端口，我的意思是，几乎对任何东西都是如此，对吧？如果你去一个网站，你不需要指定端口，你知道的，有默认值的。不，你确实需要指定端口，呃，如果你去……比方说，在你的浏览器里输入 google.com，你不会去……你不会这么做，但浏览器会。是的，但是浏览器有一个默认值，比如默认情况下它会连接到……是多少？80端口，我想，对吧？是的，80端口，对吧。所以你可以在维基百科上看到一个列表……
of the most common port number for each application. And Telnet is 23 because they put it on for testing and it's still there. So if you may open whenever you open a Telnet connection in the TTY window of your laptop, it's connecting to Socket 23. Right. Yep. In fact, then later, and this is really terrible.
每个应用程序最常见的端口号。Telnet 是 23，因为他们把它放在那儿用于测试，而且它现在还在那儿。所以如果你可能在打开时……每当你在笔记本电脑的 TTY 窗口中打开一个 Telnet 连接时，它都在连接到套接字 23。对。是的。事实上，后来，这真的很糟糕。
In 1975, when we put the first Unix system on the net, we hacked file IO to do it. So what you would type is open UCSD slash Teldat. And we give you a Telnet connection. Yep. Yep. That's right. There are no domain names in 75. However, a few years later, when they were getting Unix ready in the BSD version of Unix, even though they had a meeting and they
在1975年，当我们将第一个 Unix 系统放到网上时，我们通过篡改文件 I/O（file IO）来做到这一点。所以你会输入的是 open UCSD slash Teldat。然后我们给你一个 Telnet 连接。是的。是的。没错。在75年还没有域名。然而，几年后，当他们在 BSD 版本的 Unix 中准备 Unix 时，尽管他们开会并且……
tried to convince him, Bill Joy insisted on doing sockets, which is a terrible API, about the worst you can expect, because now every application had to be modified to use the net. Right. And it exposes the internal workings of the layer. Treating them as files was a whole lot better. In fact, I've heard that Microsoft's adoption of IPv6 was delayed two years while they had to change all of the programs that access the net because Socket's now dealt with larger addresses. Yeah, I believe it. Yeah, I think it kind of went the other direction where now you can actually use the Socket
试图说服他，比尔·乔伊（Bill Joy）坚持要做套接字（sockets），这是一个糟糕的 API，几乎是你所能期望的最糟糕的，因为现在必须修改每个应用程序才能使用网络。对。而且它暴露了层的内部工作原理。把它们当作文件看待要好得多。事实上，我听说微软采纳 IPv6 被推迟了两年，因为他们不得不修改所有访问网络的程序，因为套接字现在处理的是更大的地址。是的，我相信。是的，我想它有点走向了另一个方向，现在你实际上可以使用套接字……
API to write and read to files. So the Socket API ended up kind of being like something that now you can use for everything. But it's not as clean as a file API. No, no, not as clean as all. So, I mean, we had it right to begin with. In fact, if we had done, and also well-known ports, you guys are too young to have ever seen this, but well-known ports are equivalent to what early operating systems did when they had jump points in low memory for the applications. Okay.
API 来对文件进行读写。所以套接字 API 最终有点变成了……现在你可以把它用于任何事情的东西。但它不如文件 API 那么干净。不，不，一点都不像文件 API 那么干净。所以，我的意思是，我们一开始就做对了。事实上，如果我们这样做了，而且还有知名端口，你们太年轻了，可能从来没见过这个，但是知名端口相当于早期操作系统在应用程序的低内存中有跳转点时所做的事情。好吧。
Early operating systems didn't run that many applications. And so they had actually allocated low memory locations in the machine, physical memory locations, for the addresses of the applications. And when you typed a command, it did an indirect jump through that location. Okay. Now, what is a low? I've seen this from back when I had a 486. There's low memory and high memory. But I have to admit, I don't know what it means.
早期的操作系统运行的应用程序没有那么多。所以它们实际上在机器中分配了低内存位置，即物理内存位置，用于应用程序的地址。当你键入一个命令时，它通过那个位置进行了一次间接跳转。好吧。现在，什么是低内存？我从我有一台 486 的时候就见过这个。有低内存和高内存。但我必须承认，我不知道它是什么意思。
So what actually is low memory? Actually, the ones with the lower numbers. Right. But semantically, yeah. Well, and the OS is down numbers. Right, but semantically, yeah. Well, and the OS is down there. Ah, okay. It's similar to how some of the ports are used by the kernel, like up to, what is it, 1024 or something, right?
所以到底什么是低内存？实际上，是数字较小的那些。对。但在语义上，是的。嗯，而且操作系统就在那些低数字区域。啊，好吧。这类似于内核使用的一些端口的方式，比如最高到……是多少？1024左右，或者别的什么，对吧？
Right, exactly. It's the same thing. Got it, okay. So if we had done the file API, we could have transitioned application names, got rid of well-known ports, and no one would have noticed. Right, right. That makes sense.
对，完全正确。是一样的东西。明白了，好吧。所以如果我们做了文件 API，我们本可以过渡应用程序名，摆脱知名端口，而没有人会注意到。对，对。这说得通。
Okay. I mean, so it'd be similar to paths. You know, like you go to google.com slash careers or something. It's almost like that's an application. I think it's a web app i guess well except that google.com a lot of there's a lot of crazy stuff going on underneath right right that illusion whereas if we had done application names you wouldn't have any of that crazy stuff yeah that makes sense also all you can do on the internet
好吧。我的意思是，所以它类似于路径。你知道的，就像你去 google.com/careers 或类似的东西。这几乎就像那是一个应用程序。我想这大概是一个网络应用吧，除了 google.com 底下有很多疯狂的事情在发生，对，对，那种错觉，而如果我们做了应用程序名，你就不会有任何那些疯狂的事情了。是的，这说得通。另外，你今天在互联网上能做的全部事情……
today is a rudimentary client server. Okay? You cannot connect to a specific instance of a program. When you connect to google.com, you get a new copy. Yep. Yep. Right? Or telnet.com.
是一个初级的客户端服务器。好吧？你无法连接到一个程序的特定实例。当你连接到 google.com 时，你会得到一个新的副本。是的。是的。对吧？或者 telnet.com。
Or telnet. When you connect to telnet or anything else. You get a new copy. Okay. You can't then connect to that specific instance. Right. Yep. Nor is there a way to connect to a specific instance with two different protocols. Yep. That makes sense. So we don't have in the internet today, we don't have application names.
或者 telnet。当你连接到 telnet 或任何其他东西时。你会得到一个新的副本。好吧。然后你无法连接到那个特定的实例。对。是的。也没有办法用两种不同的协议连接到一个特定的实例。是的。这说得通。所以我们在今天的互联网中，没有应用程序名。
We don't have node addresses. The IP address is technically naming the same thing the MAC address is. And this is the root of most problems. There's no solution to the multi-homing problem, which is the Tinker Air Force Base thing I talked about. Mobility, actually, if you have a full addressing architecture, you don't need any new protocols for due mobility. That makes sense. Yeah. One of the things I read up on a while back was, I think it's called SMTP, but it's basically like a Dirichlet distribution kind of applied over a set of endpoints to try and deal with homing. So it's sort of like,
我们没有节点地址。IP 地址在技术上命名的东西和 MAC 地址命名的东西是一样的。这就是大多数问题的根源。多归属（multi-homing）问题没有解决方案，也就是我刚才谈到的丁克空军基地（Tinker Air Force Base）的事情。移动性，实际上，如果你有一个完整的寻址架构，你根本不需要任何新的协议来实现移动性。这说得通。是的。我前段时间了解的事情之一是，我想它被称为 SMTP，但它基本上就像是一个狄利克雷分布（Dirichlet distribution），某种程度上应用在一组端点上，试图处理归属问题。所以它有点像……
you know, you use a stun server or something and say, okay, this is my public address. Here's my internal address. I don't know which one you should reach me on. And then SMTP will just like try all of them and get confident about one. Yeah, SMTP is a variation on, well, it's the mail protocol. Oh, no, sorry. I'm thinking of something else. Maybe I'm thinking of there is one for VoIP. Oh, that's what it is. SCTP. Yes. SCTP. Yeah, they fixed multi-homing by changing the definition. Yeah. Well, CTP. Yeah, they fix multi-homing by changing the definition. Yeah. Well, I think they just stochastically fire at all of them, right?
你知道的，你使用一个 stun 服务器或类似的东西，然后说：“好吧，这是我的公网地址。这是我的内网地址。我不知道你应该用哪一个联系我。”然后 SMTP 就会（类似于）尝试所有这些并对其中一个充满信心。是的，SMTP 是……的一种变体，嗯，它是邮件协议。哦，不，等等。我在想别的。也许我在想的是，有一个是针对 VoIP 的。哦，就是那个！SCTP。是的。SCTP。是的，他们通过改变定义解决了多归属问题。是的。嗯，CCTP。是的，他们通过改变定义解决了多归属问题。是的。嗯，我想他们只是随机地向所有这些地址开火，对吧？
It's great for sending. It's not so much for receiving. Well, they have to do the same thing to you, right? So they have to be running a CTP and hitting you on all these different addresses. If you fix it right, then it just works. Yeah. Let me add a little bit of context here because this is actually something I know a decent amount about.
它非常适合发送。不太适合接收。嗯，他们也必须对你做同样的事情，对吧？所以他们必须运行 SCTP，并在所有这些不同的地址上打击你。如果你把它修复对，那么它就能正常工作。是的。让我在这里添加一点背景信息，因为这实际上是我相当了解的事情。
So right now, you might go and contact google.com and that might go through so many different machines. And it might get to the point where if you were to go to google.com again, you would end up at a different machine. And that creates problems because you need some kind of state usually. so what happens is all these machines they all tell google hey if you want to talk to this person who just reached you so you can return them you
所以现在，你可能会去联系 google.com，这可能会穿过许多不同的机器。而且它可能会到达这样一种地步：如果你再次访问 google.com，你最终会到达一台不同的机器。这会产生问题，因为你通常需要某种状态。所以发生的情况是，所有这些机器，它们都告诉 Google：“嘿，如果你想和刚刚联系你的这个人对话，以便你可以向他们返回……
know the logo or something you know here's a path that will get you back to where you started and and if you follow this path you're good. But if you don't have those link backs and you just try and talk to this person, you're not going to get them. And so, yeah. Now you know why there are cookies. Yeah, cookies are, yeah, cookies is basically like a little key value store
你知道，徽标或其他东西，你知道，这里有一条路径可以把你带回你开始的地方，如果你遵循这条路径，你就没问题。”但是如果你没有这些反向链接，而只是试图和这个人对话，你就找不到他们。所以，是的。现在你知道为什么有 Cookie 了。是的，Cookie 是……是的，Cookie 基本上就像是一个小的键值存储……
that you send to the server every time, yeah. Right, right, right. Yeah, but if I remember correctly, there's like a routing table. And so all the machines know where a packet came from. And in that one specific instance, you're allowed to go all the way back to that machine without knowing where it came from.
你每次都发送给服务器，对吧。对，对，对。是的，但如果我没记错的话，有一个路由表。所以所有的机器都知道一个数据包来自哪里。在那个特定的实例中，你被允许一路返回到那台机器，而不需要知道它是从哪里来的。
There's a lot of machination going on that doesn't need to be there. Yeah, right, right. Okay. And to some extent, I mean, well, to get back to what we were sort of talking about, how should I go about this?
有大量的运作机制在那里，其实并不需要存在。嗯，对，对。好吧。在某种程度上，我的意思是，嗯，回到我们刚才讨论的话题，我该怎么着手处理这个？
Of the four protocols we could have picked, or the four or five at the time, TCP was the worst. So why was that? If you analyze those protocols carefully, the two big things in TCP that are different is that there's only one header format. There's only one packet type.
在我们当时可以挑选的四个协议中，或者当时四五个协议中，TCP 是最差的。那么为什么会这样呢？如果你仔细分析这些协议，TCP 中不同的两个大点是：只有一个报头格式。只有一个数据包类型。
Everything is the same way. That makes for a very large header. Okay. Second of all, the sequence numbers number the bytes, not the packets. Really? Yes. Wait, what's the distinction there? So like, if you know the size of a packet, then you kind of know what sequence numbers actually. When TCP was proposed, there was no IP. Okay. And they knew they would have to fragment at gateways between networks. Right.
所有东西都是以相同的方式处理的。这导致了一个非常大的报头。好吧。其次，序列号对字节进行编号，而不是对数据包。真的吗？是的。等等，这两者有什么区别？所以，如果你知道一个数据包的大小，那么你基本上就知道序列号实际上……当 TCP 被提出时，还没有 IP。好吧。而且他们知道他们必须在网络之间的网关进行分片。对。
There's two ways of doing fragmentation. I can either have a sequence number and an offset that says, here's the sequence number of this packet and all of its fragments. There's the zeroth one. And then whatever the length is of the first fragment, that's the offset for the next one, and so on. Or I can do it in bytes, and then the byte number becomes the sequence number. Right. Yeah. Okay. This has a couple of problems. Okay. First of all, your sequence number space is going to turn over a lot faster. Okay. In fact, even when TCP was proposed around 74, 75, people were going, hey, man, on a satellite channel, you could roll over the sequence number space.
有两种分片方式。我既可以有一个序列号和一个偏移量，它说：“这里是这个数据包及其所有分片的序列号。这是第0个。然后无论第一个分片的长度是多少，这就是下一个分片的偏移量，依此类推。”或者我可以用字节来做，然后字节号就变成了序列号。对。是的。好吧。这有几个问题。好吧。首先，你的序列号空间会更快地用完并循环。好吧。事实上，甚至在74、75年左右提出 TCP 时，人们就在说：“嘿，老兄，在卫星信道上，你可能会把序列号空间用完并回绕。”
You don't want to have two packets with the same sequence number in the net at the same time. You know, that's just a bummer for everybody. The other problem is that TCP does not require you to retransmit on the same byte boundaries. Oh, no. Okay, that is a problem. So now you're getting that's like well now you're getting like uh fragments that are missing and then you have to go back and say okay i got enough packets for this tiny sliver retransmission that overlaps yeah if someone sends you three packets um you could end up with uh what
你绝对不想在网络中同时有两个具有相同序列号的数据包。你知道的，这对每个人来说都是一件扫兴的事。另一个问题是，TCP 不要求你在相同的字节边界上重新传输。哦，不。好吧，这确实是个问题。所以现在你会得到……这就像是……好吧，现在你得到了……呃，丢失的分片，然后你必须回去说：“好吧，我收到了这个小片段的足够的数据包。”重传会重叠。是的，如果有人给你发送了三个数据包，嗯，你最终可能会得到……呃，什么……
two you know five retransmissions or something like that. Well, or you can end up with retransmissions that overlap. Yep, yep. And now you've got to pick out what you don't have and what you do have. Now, there's one way around this, which is, oh, I do a circle queue, and I have a contiguous block of memory for this connection, so that all I have to do is overwrite it. Right, right. Okay?
两个（你知道的）五次重传或类似的东西。嗯，或者你可能会得到重叠的重传。是的，是的。现在你必须挑出你没有的和你有的。现在，有一种方法可以解决这个问题，那就是，哦，我做一个循环队列（circle queue），我为这个连接分配一块连续的内存，这样我所要做的就是覆盖它。对，对。好吧？
That's simple. If I've got it in a linked list, this is a bear. Yep, yep. Okay? There's just one problem with doing the circle queue. We've known since 1968 that statically allocating buffers to connections is grossly inefficient, like three or four orders of magnitude. Yep, that makes sense. Because, yeah, you have this block, and the block by itself doesn't really tell
这很简单。如果我把它放在链表中，这就太痛苦了。是的，是的。好吧？这样做只有一个问题。我们从1968年就知道，为连接静态分配缓冲区是极其低效的，大概有三到四个数量级。是的，这说得通。因为，是的，你有这个块，而这个块本身并没有真正告诉……
you anything, and so you have to be scanning through it. Well, no, no makes sense. Because, yeah, you have this block and the block by itself doesn't really tell you anything. And actually, what's funny is it took until 2004 for them to discover the same thing about routers. But in 1968, Peter Denning did it for terminals okay and he started with 50 users and 750 bytes of buffer space and he did a queuing model and he showed that with pool the probability of running out of buffers was 0.006 but if you static, it was 0.9. Oh, wow. If you went to 1,000 bytes, the pooled case dropped to 10 to the minus 6, and the static case dropped to three quarters. Okay. Okay? You have to go to 4,500 bytes to get the same performance you had at 750. Right, right.
你任何信息，所以你必须扫描它。嗯，不，不，这说得通。因为，是的，你有这个块，而这个块本身并没有真正告诉你任何信息。实际上，有趣的是，直到2004年他们才对路由器发现了同样的事情。但在1968年，彼得·丹宁（Peter Denning）为终端做过这方面的研究，好吧，他从50个用户和 750 字节的缓冲区空间开始，他做了一个排队模型，并表明通过池化，用完缓冲区的概率是 0.006，但如果是静态的，则是 0.9。哦，哇。如果你将容量增加到 1000 字节，池化情况下的概率下降到 10 的负 6 次方，而静态情况下的概率下降到四分之三。好吧。好吧？你必须去到 4500 字节才能获得你在 750 字节时获得的相同性能。对，对。
That makes sense. Yeah. Okay. So while a continuous memory, you know, continuous block of data per TCP connection would work and be simple, it's not what you want to do. Especially as the bandwidth delay product gets larger and larger. So then you're stuck, you know, kind of iterating through all these linked lists to find out what you're missing. Right. And then they separate IP from TCP. Yeah. So what does that mean? I've heard that, but I don't quite have a mental model of what that means.
这说得通。是的。好吧。因此，虽然连续内存（你知道的），每个 TCP 连接一块连续的数据块会起作用并且很简单，但这不是你想做的事情。特别是随着带宽延迟积越来越大。所以接下来你就会卡住，（你知道的）不得不遍历所有这些链表来找出你缺少什么。对。然后他们把 IP 从 TCP 中分离出来了。是的。那么这意味着什么？我听说过这个，但我对这意味着什么并没有一个好的心智模型。
Like, what is the distinction? There were two different protocols. There was one protocol, and they made it into two. And so what does IP do, and what does TCP do? Well, IP, okay, TCP has port numbers and no addresses, okay? IP has addresses, fragmentation, and a type of service field. And a couple other things, but they don't matter anymore. Wait, so IP doesn't have port number? No.
比如，有什么区别？有两套不同的协议。本来是一个协议，他们把它分成了两个。那么 IP 做什么，TCP 又做什么呢？嗯，IP，好吧，TCP 有端口号和节点地址，好吧？IP 有地址、分片和一个服务类型字段。还有其他几个字段，但它们不再重要了。等等，所以 IP 没有端口号？没有。
I see. But I see the TCP has a port number and then like an endpoint or something that gets from IP? No, no, no. This is one of the confusions that these guys don't really understand addresses okay when they allocated the address box they divided it up into a network part and a host part okay now someone along the line excuse me somebody got the idea that this is addressed two different things it doesn't It addresses this one thing. In fact, I recently had a discussion
我明白了。但我看到 TCP 有端口号，然后还有从 IP 获取的类似端点之类的小东西？不，不，不。这就是这些家伙不真正理解地址的困惑之一，好吧。当他们分配地址块时，他们把它分成了网络部分和主机部分。好吧。现在，不知怎么的，有人冒出了一个想法：这个地址指向两个不同的东西。其实不是。它只指向一个东西。事实上，我最近和网上的一个人进行了一次讨论，他和我资历一样老。我最后告诉他，因为总是有关于“IP 地址实际上命名的是什么？它是进程吗？是库吗？网卡吗？”的辩论。
with one of the guys in the net who's been around as long as I have. And I finally told him, because there was always a debate about, well, what is the IP address name actually? Is it a process? Is it a library? A NIC card?
无论什么。我说，我最终得出的结论是，IP 地址命名的东西就是无论剥离了 IP 报头之后剩下的什么东西。啊，是的，这说得通。对吧？现在，如果你看看这个地址，好吧，现在，这是另一件让我大开眼界的事。哦，等等，等一下，我只想重申这一点，因为现在我认为它开始豁然开朗了。所以这个想法是，你知道，IP 带你从……
Whatever. And I said, I finally came to the conclusion what the IP address names is whatever strips off the IP header. Ah, yeah, that makes sense. Right? Now, if you look at the address, okay, now, this is another thing that just blew my mind oh wait hang on i just want to reiterate this because now i think it's starting to click so the idea is you know ip gets you from
计算机从节点到节点，现在你到了那个节点，所以在这一点上，节点的地址已经不重要了，你已经在那儿了，所以真正重要的是端口是什么（你知道的），以便我可以对话……不，不，不。实际上，我在我的课堂上做过一个演示，我们从两个应用程序和两台计算机之间的 IPC（进程间通信）开始。或者实际上，一台计算机。我们从一台计算机开始。
computer from node to node and now you're at that node so at this point the address of the node doesn't matter anymore you're already there and so what really matters is what is the port you know so that i can talk no No, no, no. Actually, I have a presentation I do for my class where we start with IPC, inter-process communication, between two applications and two computers. Or actually, one computer. We start with one computer.
我们了解它是如何工作的。然后我们转到两个应用程序和两台计算机。然后我们转到多于两个应用程序和多于两台计算机。然后我们转到多于两个应用程序和多于两台计算机。好吧。在这一点上，你必须能够区分哪些数据包属于哪些连接。好吧。现在，在早期，非常早期，有些人说：“哦，好吧，一端将从字的一端开始编号，另一端将从字的另一端开始编号。我们希望它们不会在中间相遇。”
We understand how that works. Then we go to two applications and two computers. Then we go to more than two applications and two computers. Then we go to more than two applications and two computers. Okay. At that point, you have to be able to distinguish what packets belong to which connections. Okay. Now, in the early days, very early days, some people said, oh, well, the one side will start numbering from one end of the word and the other one will start numbering from the other end of the word. We hope they don't meet in the middle.
对，对。是的，嗯，好吧，但这并不好。然后另一个人说：“嘿，我们有这些端口 ID，它们本质上是使用这个连接的家伙与连接之间的文件描述符。让我们把它们连接起来，用它们作为连接 ID。”好吧，我来向听众解释一件事。所以我想我明白你在说什么了。所以当你真正连接到 Google 或任何地方时……
Right, right. Yeah, well, OK, but not great. And then somebody else said, hey, we have these port IDs that are essentially the file descriptor between the guy using this connection and the connection. Let's just concatenate them and use them as a connection ID. Okay, let me just explain something to the audience out there. So I think I get what you're saying. So when you actually make a connection to Google or anywhere,
我在这里以 Google 为例，但你可以用任何东西替换 Google。当你去连接某样东西时，你实际上指定了一个端口。你的机器实际上为该连接指定了一个端口。很多人都不知道这一点。所以这在底层的工作方式是，你的计算机保留了——我想是 32,768 到 65,536，类似这样的范围，或者是 535。这部分数字空间是为出站端口保留的。所以，例如，如果你运行一个服务……如果你想使用它们，它们也被保留用于入站连接。
I'm using Google as an example here, but you can replace Google with anything. When you go and make a connection to something, you actually assign a port. Your machine actually assigns a port for that connection. A lot of people don't know this. And so the way this works under the hood is your computer has reserved, I think it's 32, 768 up to 65, 536 like that or 535. That space of numbers is reserved for outgoing ports. So, for example, if you ran a server. They're reserved for incoming ones too if you want to use them.
它们只是不对知名端口开放。对。只是不对知名端口开放。对，所以如果你……我们实际上——我前几天在工作时遇到这种情况，有一个服务想在我的机器上运行，端口是……我想是 41,000 左右，大多数时候它都很好，有一次我重启了，然后说：“哦，我的天，这个服务无法运行，因为那个端口正在被使用。”我想：“这真是太奇怪了，我们有两个这个服务器的副本在运行。”所以我到处搜寻，我想：“好吧，最后我运行 lsof 来查找谁在占用这个端口。”结果发现它只是一个出站连接，就像某个连接到 AppleCare 或类似服务的连接，随便挑了那个端口，因为高于 32K 数字的任何端口对任何人来说都是可以公平使用的。所以，所以，是的，对于两台计算机之间的任何连接，源（它将具有某个非常高的端口号）正在连接到目标（希望——在这个例子中没有发生，但希望——它有一个较低的端口号），这样你就不会最终发生冲突。所以正如你所说，如果你把这两个端口号连结在一起，现在你就拥有了针对该连接独一无二的东西。就像我说的，一旦你不再去考虑 IP。
They're just not open for well-known ports. Right. just not open for well-known ports right so like if you uh we actually i had this at work the other day where there was a service that wanted to run on my machine on port uh i think it was like 41,000 and most of the time it was fine and one time i restarted and said oh my the service can't run because that port is being used and i thought well that's really that's really strange we have two copies of this server running so i'm digging around i'm like okay finally i run lsof to can't run because that port is being used. And I thought, well, that's really strange. We have two copies of this server running. So I'm digging around. I'm like, okay, finally, I run LSOF to find out who's on this port. And it's just an outgoing connection, like some connection that's
它们只是对知名端口不开放。对，就是对知名端口不开放。所以比如你，其实我前几天在工作时就遇到过这种情况，有个服务想在我的机器上运行，端口是...我想大概是 41,000 左右。大多数时候都没问题，但有一次我重启后，它说“天哪，服务无法运行，因为那个端口被占用了”。我想，这真的很奇怪，我们运行了两个这个服务器的副本。所以我开始排查，心想，好吧，最后我运行 lsof 来查看谁占用了这个端口——结果发现那只是一个出站连接，比如某个连接到...的连接，无法运行是因为那个端口被占用了。我想，这真的很奇怪，我们运行了两个这个服务器的副本。所以我开始排查，心想，好吧，最后我运行 lsof 来查看到底是谁在使用这个端口。结果发现它只是一个出站连接，就像某个
going to AppleCare or something, just pick that port because it's anything above that 32K number is fair for anyone to use. And so, so yeah so for any connection between two computers the source which is going to have some really high port number is connecting to the destination which hopefully i mean didn't happen in this case but hopefully has a lower port number so that you don't end up with a conflict and so to your point if you stick the two if you if you concatenate the two port numbers now you have something that's unique for that. Like once again, once you've stopped thinking about IP.
正连接到 AppleCare 之类的连接，刚好选中了那个端口，因为只要大于 32K 的端口号任何人都可以随意使用。所以，是的，对于两台计算机之间的任何连接，源端口（通常是一个非常高的端口号）会连接到目标端口（希望如此——虽然在这个例子中并没有发生，但通常目标端口应该是一个较低的端口号），这样就不会导致冲突。正如你所说，如果你把这两个端口号串联起来，你就会得到一个针对该连接的唯一标识。就像我说的，一旦你不再去考虑 IP 地址。
It's unique within the context of the two IP addresses. Right, right. Okay. Yeah, that's good. Now you would think that if you were going to split this protocol off, that now if you had a choice between doing it in a way that everything works or doing it in a way that's broken, which one would you choose? The working way, I think, sounds pretty great.
这在两个 IP 地址的语境下是独一无二的。对，对。好的。是的，这很好。现在你会觉得，如果你打算把这个协议分离开来，那么如果你现在面临一个选择：是用一种一切都能正常运作的方式来做，还是用一种破损的方式来做，你会选哪个？我想，正常运作的方式听起来相当不错。
Well, actually, they didn't. They chose the way that broke. So what did they choose? Because you lost me there. Well, IP fragmentation doesn't work. And it never has. What is IP fragmentation? Well, remember we said that when you go between networks, you may have a different MTU number and maximum transmission unit.
嗯，实际上，他们没有。他们选择了破损的那种。那他们选了什么？因为你刚才把我绕糊涂了。嗯，IP 分片根本不起作用。而且从来都没起过作用。什么是 IP 分片？嗯，还记得我们说过，当你在不同网络之间传输时，你可能会有不同的 MTU 数字，也就是最大传输单元。
And, you know, you have to fragment the packets. Right, right. Right. Well, IP fragmentation has never worked. Oh, I see. Okay, so you're saying, you know, okay, so just to recap, so you send a packet out, and every packet has a
而且，你知道，你必须对数据包进行分片。对，对。对。嗯，IP 分片从来就没有真正起过作用。哦，我明白了。好吧，你是说，嗯，好吧，我们来总结一下，你发送一个数据包，每个数据包都有一个
size. Yep, and so then it gets to a machine, and that machine has an MTU, which I think is maximum. It's another network that has a maximum transmission unit of, say, 200 bytes. Right. And so it has to get broken up.
大小。没错，然后它到达一台机器，这台机器有一个 MTU，我记得这是最大值。这是另一个网络，其最大传输单元比方说只有 200 字节。对。所以它必须被拆分。
Right. And so you're saying breaking it up at the IP level doesn't work. So I think, well, how does it even happen in practice because you don't have the sequence number at the IP level? Well, actually, what you have, that's one thing I left out. One of the things you have in the IP header is a packet number, 16 bits. Oh, okay. And an offset. Okay.
对。所以你是说在 IP 层进行拆分是行不通的。那么我想，这在实际中到底是怎么发生的呢，因为你在 IP 层没有序列号？嗯，实际上，你拥有的是——这也是我刚才漏掉的一点。你在 IP 头部中拥有的东西之一就是数据包编号，16 位。哦，好吧。还有一个偏移量。好吧。
So now you have two sequence numbers in TCP. Yeah, there's the rub. Yeah, right. Right? Because IP doesn't do retransmission. Right. So if you miss half of an IP packet, you either have to say this whole TCP packet is hosed or you have to try and do something really clever. Well, no.
所以现在你在 TCP 中有两个序列号了。是的，问题就出在这儿。对，没错。对吧？因为 IP 不负责重新传输。对。所以如果你丢失了一半的 IP 数据包，你要么得说整个 TCP 数据包都报废了，要么你就得尝试做一些非常巧妙的事情。呃，其实不然。
I mean, that's what happens is, you know, you send it. One of the fragments gets lost. You store it. And now you have to wait five seconds to age it in case the packet's late. TCP is going to retransmit before that. Yep. Yep. Which is going to give it a new sequence number, which gives a new packet number,
我的意思是，实际情况是，你知道，你把它发送出去。其中一个分片丢失了。你把它存起来。现在你必须等待五秒钟让它老化，以防数据包只是延迟了。TCP 在那之前就会重新传输了。没错。没错。这将赋予它一个新的序列号，从而产生一个新的数据包编号，
which goes through the network and maybe loses one. Right. Right. And this just gets out of control. Two copies of the same packet partially assembled, but the destination doesn't know that. Yep. Okay? So it doesn't work. Now we have a solution
它会穿过网络，可能又会丢失一个。对。对。这简直失控了。同一数据包的两个副本被部分组装，但目的地对此一无所知。没错。好吧？所以这行不通。现在我们有了一个解决方案，
called PathMTU Discovery. You send a ping with a certain size of data, and you set the don't fragment bit and if it comes back and says, sorry, I couldn't deliver, it's too big, then you do it again with a smaller one
叫做路径 MTU 发现（Path MTU Discovery）。你发送一个带有特定大小数据且设置了“不要分片”标志的 ping，如果它返回并说：“抱歉，我无法交付，它太大了”，然后你就用更小的数据大小再试一次，
until you find one that works. Yeah, I mean, similar to our SCTP story where to your earlier point, you don't have an elegant system anymore. And so now you go down this rabbit hole of empirics where you just try and blast things. And basically, you're building like a particle filter of appropriate MTU size. To jump ahead a little bit, one of the exercises I did, Bill Wolf in the 70s wrote a paper on operating systems in which he talked about the separation of mechanism and policy. And the point was that the mechanism was often the same.
直到你找到一个能行得通的大小。是的，我的意思是，这类似于我们的 SCTP 故事，正如你之前所说，你不再拥有一个优雅的系统了。于是现在你陷入了经验主义的兔子洞，盲目地狂轰滥炸。基本上，你在构建一个适当 MTU 大小的粒子过滤器。稍微扯远一点，我做过的练习之一，比尔·沃尔夫（Bill Wolf）在 70 年代写过一篇关于操作系统的论文，其中他谈到了机制与策略的分离。重点在于，机制往往是相同的。
The only thing that changed was policy. So, for example, the machinery for taking one process off the machine, putting in a queue and starting another one was the same. The question was, which one do you run next? That was the policy. Is it round robin? Is it first come, first serve? What is it? Right.
唯一改变的是策略。例如，将一个进程从机器中移出、放入队列并启动另一个进程的 machinery（机制）是相同的。问题是，接下来运行哪一个？这就是策略。是轮询调度（round robin）？还是先来先服务（first come, first serve）？到底是什么？对。
Same thing with memory management. OK. Well, I always thought it was really odd that this is taught in every operating system textbook I've ever read, but never mentioned in networks where, you know, the machinery for doing acknowledgements is always the same. The question is, when do you do it? The thing about extending credit for flow control is always the same. The question is how much? Right? So it seemed to be really applicable. So, you know, and I got this, I had this real insight one day. We always thought we'd do another version of transport for voice because you care about order, but you don't care about gaps, which we were saying about your gaming thing.
内存管理也是如此。好的。嗯，我一直觉得很奇怪，我在读过的每一本操作系统教科书中都会教这一点，但在网络领域却从不提及。你知道，用于确认（acknowledgements）的 machinery 总是相同的。问题是，你什么时候做？关于为流量控制扩展信用的事情总是相同的。问题是多少？对吧？所以这似乎真的很适用。所以，你知道，我得到了这个启发，有一天我突然有了一个真正的顿悟。我们一直以为我们会为语音传输开发另一个版本的传输层，因为你关心顺序，但你不在乎间隙，正如我们之前谈论你的游戏业务时所说的那样。
Right? If it's a small gap, who cares? Nobody's going to notice it. Yep. And then I realized that we didn't need a new version of transport. We just changed the act policy. You lie. You say you got it.
对吧？如果是一个小间隙，谁在乎呢？没人会注意到的。没错。然后我意识到我们根本不需要新版本的传输层。我们只需改变 ACK 策略。你在说谎。你说你收到了。
There's nothing in these protocols that says you have to tell the truth. So, well, I thought, so now this is where you'll have to educate me on this, because now there's not only TCP, there's UDP. And so with UDP, yeah, you don't have to acknowledge, right? Let me think. So actually, that also told me something else, that we'd had the semantics of acknowledgement wrong all these years. Acknowledgement doesn't mean I got it. Acknowledgement means I'm not going to ask you to retransmit it. It's subtle, but it's major. Oh, and this gets back to your
这些协议中没有任何规定要求你必须说实话。所以，嗯，我想，现在这就是你得给我上课的地方了，因为现在不仅有 TCP，还有 UDP。所以对于 UDP 来说，是的，你不需要进行确认，对吧？让我想想。所以实际上，这也告诉我另一件事，我们这些年来把确认的语义搞错了。确认并不意味着“我收到了”。确认意味着“我不会要求你重新传”。这很微妙，但非常重要。哦，这又回到了你的
sequence number thing, right? Because if you get sequence number one and three, then you could go back and say, hey, I got two, even though you didn't get it. I can say I got three. I got three. That acknowledges everything before that. Well, well, okay. So if you want to be reliable, you would say, I got one, I got three, I didn't get two, please resend it. If you don't want to be reliable, you say, I got one, I got three, I'm missing two. If it's all based on bytes, you know, you get one and then you get 350. And then it really becomes weird. Like how many packets did I actually miss? You don't know. But, you know, but it works a little differently, but you got the basic idea, right? So I went through and did separation of mechanism of policy for all of the mechanisms and protocols
序列号问题，对吧？因为如果你收到了序列号 1 和 3，那么你可以回过头来说，嘿，我收到 2 了，尽管你实际上并没有收到它。我可以宣称我收到 3 了。我收到 3 了。这就确认了之前的所有内容。嗯，好吧。所以，如果你想要可靠性，你会说：我收到了 1，我收到了 3，我没收到 2，请重新发送。如果你不想要可靠性，你会说：我收到了 1，我收到了 3，我漏掉了 2。如果这一切都基于字节，你知道，你收到了 1，然后你收到了 350。那事情就真的变得诡异了。比如我到底漏掉了多少个包？你根本不知道。但是，你知道，虽然运作方式略有不同，但你懂基本原理，对吧？所以我通读并实践了所有机制和协议的机制与策略分离，
like TCP. And when I put it together, it was really interesting because the mechanisms cleaved naturally into two different groups. Those that had to be with the data, sequence numbers, where else could they be? Right. And those that could be but didn't have to be, Acknowledgements and flow control. Now, notice that the first set in policy is imposed by the sender. And the second set are feedback mechanisms where policy is imposed by the receiver. And the two pieces barely talk to each other. The part that has to be with the data records what sequence number comes in, and the feedback stuff reads that and decides what to do in terms of acknowledgements and flow control. And the only time it interacts with the other part is to say, hey, wait a minute,
比如 TCP。当我把它们整合在一起时，真的非常有趣，因为这些机制很自然地裂变成两组。那些必须与数据绑定的机制——序列号，它们还能在哪儿呢？对。以及那些可以绑定但并非必须绑定的机制——确认和流量控制。现在，请注意，第一组中的策略是由发送方强加的。第二组则是反馈机制，其策略是由接收方强加的。这两部分几乎互不交流。必须与数据绑定的部分记录了进来的序列号，而反馈机制则读取这些内容，并决定在确认和流量控制方面做出什么动作。它与另一部分互动的唯一时刻就是说：嘿，等等，
the flow control window's closed, you can't send anything. That's it. There's no interaction. If you cleave the protocol that way, then the whole problem of IP fragmentation not working goes away. In other words, if you join UDP and IP together, and if you want reliability, you throw in the feedback mechanisms, there's no problem. Yeah, so there are like reliable UDP protocols in user space. There's not a kernel protocol. No, that's an illusion.
流量控制窗口已经关闭了，你什么也发不了。仅此而已。没有任何其他互动。如果你以这种方式切分协议，那么 IP 分片无法运作的整个问题就迎刃而解了。换句话说，如果你将 UDP 和 IP 结合在一起，并且如果你需要可靠性，你只需加入反馈机制，就没有任何问题了。是的，所以在用户空间中存在类似可靠的 UDP 协议。并没有一个内核协议。不，那是一种幻觉。
So reliable UDP, I think the way it works. You mean there are protocols built on top of UDP that are reliable? Exactly, yeah. Yeah, okay, all right. That I'll buy. Yeah. Right. And so, and so, uh, actually this is like, uh, and I want us to spend a little bit of time. That's like saying I could build a reliable protocol on top of IP. Right. Right.
所以可靠的 UDP，我想它是这样运作的。你是说有建立在 UDP 之上且具备可靠性的协议？完全正确，是的。是的，好吧，没问题。这个我认可。是的。对。所以，所以，呃，实际上这就像是，呃，我想花点时间讨论一下。这就好比说我可以在 IP 之上构建一个可靠的协议。对。对。
So like, what is the, you know, um, what is the advantage of, um, doing things at the kernel level, like making a new protocol versus building a reliable UDP? One of the things that was developed in the 80s that the Internet dearly loves to hate was an encoding scheme called ASN1. And they thought it was just an encoding scheme. But actually, it was different. It was what ASN1, ASN stands for abstract syntax notation. It was an abstract syntax notation and encoding rules. Think of the abstract, I mean, it's a mouthful, but think of the abstract syntax as what you would write in a program. Coding rules is what the code generators would do. Okay. So I could have, you know, so for
所以就像，你知道，嗯，在内核层做事情的优势是什么，比如制作一个新协议与构建一个可靠的 UDP 相比？80 年代发展起来的一项技术是互联网深恶痛绝的，那就是一种名为 ASN.1 的编码方案。他们以为它只是一种编码方案。但实际上，它完全不同。它是——ASN，ASN 代表抽象语法符号（Abstract Syntax Notation）。它是一种抽象语法符号以及编码规则。你可以这样理解抽象语法，我的意思是，这拗口得很，但你可以把抽象语法想象成你在程序中编写的内容。而编码规则则是代码生成器所做的事情。好吧。所以你可以拥有，你知道，举个
example, there's one set of encoding rules that's very verbose and you can have the fields in any order and all sorts of stuff, but it's fairly, you know, bandwidth inefficient. There are other encoding rules that are very bandwidth efficient to the point that if you compress it, it gets, you know, it gets bigger instead of smaller. What it's really telling you is that I can make protocols invariant with respect to syntax. Okay. So for example, in a transport protocol, I've got these silly fields and they're either used for two, one of two reasons, hashing into a table to look up an address or a port number, or doing a simple arithmetic modulus, the width of the field, on sequence numbers. The procedure is the same, right?
例子，有一套编码规则非常冗长，你可以让字段以任何顺序排列以及各种乱七八糟的东西，但它在带宽效率上相当，你知道，相当低效。还有另一套编码规则，其带宽效率极高，甚至到了如果你去压缩它，它反而，你知道，会变大而不是变小的程度。它真正向你传达的是，我可以让协议对语法保持不变。好吧。例如，在传输协议中，我有这些愚蠢的字段，它们要么用于以下两个原因之一：散列到表中以查找地址或端口号，或者对序列号进行简单的算术模运算（字段的宽度）。这个过程是一样的，对吧？
So what you really come down to is there's really only one data transfer protocol. And also, I'll throw in a ringer, which I've gotten a lot of controversy and pushback from our guys on. I think UDP should be thrown out. There should be no flows in a network that are not flow control. Oh, interesting. It's a denial of service vector. If I've got flow control, I can shut it down. Yeah, there's the, like your router will do quality of service and these kind of things, but it's not quite flow control. It's like a, you know, trying to solve the same problem. Well, it tries, but it's got the transport layer working against it, which is another problem.
所以你真正得出的结论是，实际上只有一个数据传输协议。此外，我要抛出一个棘手的问题，这曾让我遭受了很多来自我们团队成员的争议和阻力。我认为应该把 UDP 丢掉。网络中不应该存在任何没有流量控制的流（flows）。哦，很有意思。这是一个拒绝服务（DoS）攻击载体。如果我有流量控制，我就可以把它关掉。是的，有那种，就像你的路由器会做服务质量（QoS）以及诸如此类的事情，但这并不完全是流量控制。这就像是，你知道，试图去解决同一个问题。嗯，它确实在尝试，但它却在与传输层作对，这又是另一个问题。
I mean, you know, because TCP congestion control is about the worst you could ever last for. Okay. First of all, it works by causing congestion. Right. Yeah. You know. Yeah, it works by saying no. And as soon as you say no, everyone wants to give it back to you.
我的意思是，你知道，因为 TCP 拥塞控制可以说是你所能忍受的最糟糕的东西了。好吧。首先，它是通过引起拥塞来发挥作用的。对。Yeah。你知道的。是的，它是通过说“不”来运作的。而一旦你说了“不”，每个人都想把包退回给你。
One of the really worst things is because it detects congestion by lost packets. It's predatory. Yeah. You can't do anything in the layer below and drop a packet because TCP will react and you'll have feedback loops working against each other. Okay.
真正糟糕的事情之一是，由于它是通过丢失的数据包来检测拥塞的。它是掠夺性的。是的。你不能在下面的层级中做任何事情并丢弃一个数据包，因为 TCP 会作出反应，最终你会得到互相冲突的反馈回路。好吧。
In 1988, there was work done by Roz Jane, then at DEC, who showed that, one, you should use ECON, explicit congestion notification. And two, notification should begin when the average queue length is greater than or equal to one. Very early, which gives you time to react so that there's no loss. Yep, that makes sense. Okay. And, you know, the thing is about what we've got in TCP now, and it really irks me that every time there's a proposal for something new,
1988 年，当时在 DEC 工作的罗兹·简（Raj Jain）做过一项研究，表明：第一，你应该使用 ECON，即显式拥塞通知（Explicit Congestion Notification）。第二，当平均队列长度大于或等于 1 时，就应该开始发出通知。非常及时，这给了你反应的时间，从而不会产生数据丢包。没错，这说得通。好吧。而且，你知道，关于我们现在在 TCP 中所拥有的东西，真正让我恼火的是，每当有关于新事物的提案出现时，
BBR, it's like, oh, everyone's just in love with BBR. It's still implicit notification. As far as I'm concerned, you haven't moved off the dime. It's not an improvement at all. Yeah. I've often said that TCP is the greatest thesis generator ever developed. Okay. Because there's no solution. I mean, also the effectiveness of any congestion scheme decreases with increasing time to notify. By putting it in TCP, you've maximized time to notify. The reason it's a great thesis generator is there is no solution to congestion in the transport layer. Before the 80s, everyone was looking at putting in the network layer. Okay?
比如 BBR，就像是，哦，每个人都对 BBR 爱不释手。这仍然是隐式通知。依我看，你们根本就原地踏步。这根本算不上什么改进。是的。我经常说 TCP 是有史以来产生最多博士论文的工具。好吧。因为根本没有解决方案。我的意思是，任何拥塞方案的有效性都会随着通知时间的增加而降低。把它放在 TCP 中，你就最大化了通知时间。它之所以能成为伟大的论文生成器，是因为在传输层根本没有解决拥塞的方案。在 80 年代之前，每个人都在考虑把它放到网络层中。好吧？
Now, you can do things. You can try various tweaks and different ways of handling, you know, you can do RED and, you know, all these things and you can get enough data to, to do a thesis. The trouble with most, all of these proposals for improving is that they're great. If you're the only one doing them, when everybody else starts doing it, it's really not much better than what you had. Yeah, that makes sense. It's like all of these best response stock kind of things. It's like, okay, I have this new algorithm to trade stocks, but it only works because not everyone is using it.
现在，你可以做一些事情。你可以尝试各种微调和不同的处理方式，你知道，你可以使用 RED，以及诸如此类的方法，你可以获得足够的数据来写一篇论文。所有这些改进提案的共同问题在于，它们都很棒。如果你是唯一一个使用它们的人，当其他所有人也开始使用时，它其实并不比你原本拥有的好多少。是的，这说得通。这就像所有这些最佳响应博弈论之类的事情。这就好比，好吧，我有这个交易股票的新算法，但它之所以奏效，仅仅是因为并非所有人都在使用它。
Not everybody's doing it. You get enough data to get a PhD thesis, and there's always another tweak somebody else can do. Yep. Right. I actually, I was doing a roundtable one time years ago and I made that comment and some guy in the audience went, hey, that's how I got mine. That's awesome. So we're going to put a bookmark in it what i think we should definitely do um you know we're going to make this a two-parter for folks out there so this isn't the the end of the
并非所有人都这么做。你获得了足够的数据来拿下一篇博士论文，而且总会有别人可以做进一步的微调。没错。对。实际上，多年前我曾参加过一次圆桌会议，我发表了那个评论，然后观众席上的某个家伙说：“嘿，我就是靠那个拿到学位的。”太棒了。所以我们要把这里做个书签，我认为我们绝对应该这样做，你知道，我们要为听众朋友们把它做成上下两集，所以这绝不是这个
story by any means um but you know what we should do um in the next episode is we should talk about you know i'm really curious like what you know uh steps can we take? I mean, both on in terms of, you know, the academic steps and also like, how do we get people out of this sort of quagmire we've gotten ourselves into? We definitely should talk about that. And we can revisit or we can visit, you know, some of these things like DNS and how all these things came about. I'm really curious to know more about this. But so we're going to call it for this episode.
故事的结局，绝非如此；但你知道我们应该在下一集里做什么吗？我们应该谈谈，你知道，我真的很好奇，我们能采取什么步骤呢？我的意思是，既包括学术层面的步骤，也包括我们如何把人们从我们现在陷入的这种泥潭中拉出来？我们绝对应该讨论这个问题。我们可以重温，或者说探讨一下，你知道，诸如 DNS 之类的事情以及所有这些东西是如何诞生的。我真的很好奇想了解更多这方面的信息。所以我们这一集就先到这里。
And then when you catch the next one in a couple of weeks, we're going to dive into all of those topics. But in the meantime, John, I wanted to thank you so much for coming into this first part here and explaining so much of the technical depth to us. This has been really fascinating. I've learned a ton. Patrick and I have learned a ton from this first part already. And thank you so much for sharing
然后当你在几周后收听下一集时，我们将深入探讨所有这些话题。但在此期间，约翰，我非常感谢你能来到这第一部分，并为我们解释了如此深度的技术内容。这真的太迷人了。我学到了超级多。我和帕特里克从这第一部分中已经学到了海量的知识。非常感谢你与我们分享
this with us. Okay. All right. Well, it was great fun. Cool. And yeah, we're really looking forward to chatting again. And for everyone out there, thanks so much for subscribing to us on Patreon. There is a super fast RSS link. If you're a subscriber, appreciate everyone doing that. And thanks for supporting us on Audible and all the various podcasting platforms. And we will see everyone in a couple of weeks. music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work,
这一切。好的。好吧，这真的非常有趣。酷。是的，我们非常期待再次聊天。对于所有的听众朋友，非常感谢大家在 Patreon 上订阅我们。那里有一个超快的 RSS 链接。如果你是订阅者，非常感谢大家的支持。也感谢大家在 Audible 以及各大播客平台上对我们的支持。我们几周后见。音乐由 Eric Barn Dollars 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享 署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议 (Creative Commons Attribution ShareAlike 2.0) 下发布。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，可以对该作品进行混编和改编，
but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但您必须署名我和帕特里克，并以相同方式进行共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。